Was macht denn die Wasserflasche hier für nervige Geräusche?
Das hier. Geh mal weg.
Warte mal. So.
Einfach richtig zu.
Vielleicht kriege ich sie klein nicht mehr auf.
So.
Ich bin heute relativ spät am Start.
Oder am Start, wie der Fabian früher immer gesagt hat.
Ich habe mir gedacht, es ist Dezember.
Und zwar mitten Dezember.
Da wird es mal wieder Zeit zu gucken,
was es zur Zeit so für High-IQ-Stellenanzeigen gibt.
Das heißt, wie immer, wenn ihr irgendwelche habt,
die wir uns zusammen angucken wollen, einfach herschicken.
Wobei, muss ich gleich sagen, der Stream ist noch gar nicht richtig angelaufen.
Da sind sechs Leute da. Glaubt nicht.
Da ist da so viel schon was.
Ah, doch, jetzt. Hallo.
Leute, da seid ihr ja.
Ich muss mal kurz meine Arch-Linux-VM anmachen,
weil Arch, by the way, erst mal updaten.
Das nervt mich bei VMWare auch, dass man das nicht wegklicken kann,
während das hier restort.
Warum?
Ich meine...
Hä?
Nicht, dass das eine irgendwie Einfluss auf das andere hätte oder so.
Also, macht eigentlich überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
So, updaten.
Updaten.
Nein.
Hier auch updaten, alles updaten.
Massive-Update-Stells.
Guck mal hier.
Oh, du Scheiße.
Was ist mit denen los?
Was geht bei JetBrains ab?
Die haben ja alles aktualisiert.
Das neue VMWare-Subscription-Model gibt es nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne das neue VMWare-Subscription-Model nicht.
Was ist denn das neue VMWare-Subscription-Model?
Wollen die jetzt auch, dass man ein Abo abschließt?
Dann können sie mich mal, ey.
Ich habe keinen Bock.
Ich habe schon so viele dumme Abos, von denen ich eigentlich viele gar nicht haben will.
Aber du nicht mal drum herum kommst.
Richtig hängengeblieben.
Also, ich kenne...
Ich kenne das neue...
Oder...
Oder ist das tatsächlich was Gescheites?
Also, ich habe keinen Plan.
Weiß nicht, was das neue VMWare-Subscription-Model ist.
Excellent.
For ever kills off licenses with only subscript.
Die können mich mal.
Ach, Broadcom gehört das Ganze.
Ja, die Quelle hört sich an nach 0815 AI generiertem Content.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber...
Ich weiß nicht, um was es da...
Also, ganz ehrlich.
Ich werde für VMWare Workstation definitiv keine Subscription, noch eine extra Subscription
im Monat abschließen.
Irgendwann...
Irgendwann ist es auch gut mit Subscriptions.
Was...
Was brauchst du noch alles?
20 Software-Subscriptions, 4 Streaming-Server-Subscriptions, 5 Musik-Subscriptions, 3 Sport-Subscriptions,
Twitch-Subscription, YouTube-Subscription...
Du subscribes dich ja kaputt.
Nee, nee, nee.
Also, irgendwann...
Irgendwann ist es gut.
Hast du mal ein VMWare Tanzu verwendet?
Verwendet...
Also, verwendet kann man nicht wirklich sagen.
Wir haben das auf der Arbeit.
Aber ich habe da keine großen Schnittmengen mit.
Also, ich kenne das.
Ich weiß, was es ist.
Das ist quasi eine Kubernetes-API-Schicht über VMWare drüber.
Aber ansonsten gar keinen Plan von so Selbstbasteln.
VMWare Business Transformation.
Alter, das hat doch wunderbar funktioniert.
Alter, was wollt ihr da transformaten?
Simplifying.
Klar, natürlich.
Ach so, gut.
Wiesvier, sonst wie gedöhnt.
Ich glaube, das hat...
Das könnte schon was mit Workstations zu tun haben.
Keine Ahnung.
Warten wir mal ab.
Ansonsten, ganz ehrlich.
Ich glaube, ich habe...
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt hier VMWare Workstation 17.
Ich glaube, ich habe von den letzten 5 VMWare-Versionen oder sowas von den neuen Features nichts
gebraucht.
Dann lasse ich erst mal 17 laufen.
Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt hier 5 VMWare Workstation 17.
Ich glaube, ich habe von den letzten 5 VMWare-Versionen oder sowas von den neuen Features nichts
gebraucht.
Dann lasse ich erst mal 17 laufen.
Nein, das wird es auf jeden Fall nicht, weil du dich trotzdem noch ein bisschen mehr selbst
drum kümmern musst.
Das ist ja gerade das Schöne an AKS oder an der Google Kubernetes-Geschichte oder an...
Wie heißt das bei AWS?
EKS, gell?
Elastic Kubernetes Service.
Die Benamung bei AWS.
wie es ist komplett peter mister game danke für den sap eks ja da ist ja noch
sehr viel neues zeug dabei also was du da machen kannst also ich glaube ich
glaube nicht ich weiß es allerdings nicht weil ich selbst damit als wir
haben das auch auf der arbeit aber ich habe es habe selbst damit so bisher sehr
wenig stadtmenge gehabt so alles geupdatet das ging tatsächlich schneller
als gedacht ach so ja auch wenn ich die vm jetzt gerade geupdatet habe ich
brauche das gar nicht musik ist bisschen laut doch alles geupdatet weiß also ich
habe mir gedacht das ist dezember leute wird mal wieder zeit zu gucken was denn
alle die immer schreien sie finden keine fachkräfte im dezember so machen so
letzte möglichkeit für viele leute noch zu kündigen
ansonsten wieder drei monate kündigungsfrist ich weiß nicht wie ist
das bei euch
also bei meinem aktuellen arbeitsvertrag weiß ich gar nicht was ich dafür
kündigungsfrist wahrscheinlich ähnlich über letzten aber beim letzten waren es
drei monate zum quartalsende aber dieses drei monate nach monate bei mir sind bei
mir waren es beim letzten mal dass drei monate zum quartalsende das heißt ich
hätte quasi hätte ich am ersten ersten gekündigt hätte ich quasi noch knapp
sechs monate bleiben müssen ist schon recht hart deswegen war es letztes jahr
auch für mich so knapp
so wirklich so offen letzten drücker dass wir das noch hingekriegt haben mit
dem neuen arbeitgeber fach ansonsten hätte ich erstmal gelitten gehabt erst
mal aski aquarium anschmeißen zur entspannung
mein ubuntu-servers ist gelegentlich nicht erreichbar vermute docker ist
schuld aber ich glaube nicht dass becker daran schuld ist dass der ubuntu server
nicht regelmäßig nicht erreichbar ist ich würde vielleicht sogar darauf
zuißen ich weiß ja nicht was du da drauf machst ja aber
Was ist das? Power Cloud.
Das ist ja ein massive, massive Name.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das überhaupt am Ubuntu-Server liegt, dass der ab und zu mal nicht erreichbar ist.
Es sei denn, du hast irgendeinen Hardware-Defekt oder du machst da drauf irgendwelche ganz abgedrehten Dinger.
Also so wie du das fragst, kann man das zumindest nicht beantworten, weil das ist ein ganz klarer großer Ausnahmefall,
wenn Ubuntu-Server oder auch Debian-Server, Deluxe-Server, selbst Windows-Server ab und zu nicht erreichbar sind.
Also entweder, vor allem wie nicht erreichbar? Web-Interface nicht erreichbar? Ist das H nicht erreichbar?
Ping geht gar nicht durch? Da kann man ja so gar nichts dazu sagen.
Also da brauchen wir schon mehr Informationen und was du machst.
Und selbst dann, glaube ich, gestaltet sich das Remote zu Debuggen als enorm schwierig.
Aber der Chat-Community-Ge...
Consultant ist am Start. Also wenn du mehr Informationen erzählst, dann können wir da vielleicht noch was zu sagen.
So, Chat-Ge, eine Runde Entspannung.
Zack. Okay.
Genug entspannt.
Chopped markant.
Ah, du findest immer Sachen hier am Start.
Ja, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Was war denn das?
Ach, das hatten wir ja das letzte Mal.
Ja, genau.
Schau mal. Jetzt geht es aber rund hier.
Polizei Bayern.
Stellenanzeige.
Ja, die bezahlen wahrscheinlich.
Wieder nix, oder?
Ja, machen wir.
Ich meine, der Titel ist relativ eindeutig, ne?
Wo habe ich jetzt die Wasserflasche...
Pass mal auf.
Ich habe die Wasserflasche vor zwei Minuten, weil sie mir auf den Keks gegangen ist, mit den Geräuschen mega fest zugemacht.
Und prophezeit, ich kriege sie jetzt nicht auf.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, ob ich da...
Fuck, Alter.
Ne, geht doch.
Geht doch.
Ging doch.
Gar kein großes Problem.
Schau mal das Bild weiter unten.
Okay, ich muss das immer auf dem zweiten Bildschirm checken.
Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration, männlich-weiß-deutsch, wie immer, Systemhaus für Dachau und München, rbs.net.com.
Was für...
Willst du unsere Echse ausführen?
Ich habe schon cringigeres gesehen.
Ich habe schon...
Aber...
Job bei Sony.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir bei...
Alter, die Stellenanzeige von Sony sieht aber auch...
...aus wie 1995, oder?
Oh, das ist mir zu einschläfern.
Moment, Moment.
Ja, irgendwie sowas hier.
Oder...
Keine Ahnung.
Sowas hier.
Irgendwas...
Ich brauche ein bisschen...
Bisschen...
Nettes Hintergrund-Gedudel.
Wo...
Aber nicht ganz so einschläfernd ist.
Ja, das ist okay.
Jetzt geht es aber heute Schlag auf Schlag.
Mann, da kommen wir gar nicht...
Wie wäre es damit?
Okay.
Ich glaube, Chat, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Wir müssen tatsächlich jetzt anfangen.
Weil...
Also, normalerweise kommen irgendwie die Anzahl über den gesamten Stream an Dinger, ne?
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Ach so, ja, auf die Frage hin.
Irgendjemand hat doch vorhin gefragt...
Ich sehe es nicht.
Irgendjemand hat doch gesagt, ja, erzähl doch mal, wie ist es denn jetzt auf deiner neuen Arbeit?
Ich sehe es nicht, wer das war.
Meinung zur neuen Twitch-Meta.
Ja.
Was ist denn die neue Twitch-Meta?
Nein, er meint die letzte.
Er meint die letzte.
Das, was ich seit April mache.
Ja.
Also, es hat sich gelohnt im Endeffekt.
Also, ich meine, der alte Arbeitgeber hatte ja schon ab dem Zeitpunkt gelitten, wo der neue gesagt hat, was die Kunst-Kategorie, die Twitch...
Was?
Wie heißt das?
Art?
Wait.
Moment.
Sekunde.
Ich muss das mal kurz auf den zweiten...
What the f...
Alter.
Was zum...
Was ist auf Twitch los?
What?
Al...
Was zum Teufel...
Alter, was geht auf Twitch, Mann?
Ist das...
Sind die Twitch-Mortgages nicht...
Nicht da, oder?
What the fuck?
Was ist...
Was ist denn mit Twitch auf einmal los?
Die haben doch immer so auf...
Familienfreundlich und safe für alle und so gemacht.
Haben die jetzt doch ein bisschen Schiss, dass Kick in die User absaugt, oder was?
Wobei, ganz ehrlich...
Ich glaube, das ist ein komplett anderes Klientel, an was ich das richte.
Also, das wundert mich jetzt doch.
Das wundert mich jetzt doch.
Die ganze Zeit haben sie irgendwelche Leute...
Noch geballt.
Weil die irgendwie...
Ihr Onlyfans-Profil verlinkt haben, oder sowas.
Und jetzt ist das Erste...
Das Erste, was ich aufmache auf meinem zweiten Vorschaubildschirm, irgendwelche Furry-Titten-Bilder, Alter.
Was zum Teufel ist da los auf Twitch?
Ja, ich dachte mir auch...
Ich dachte mir auch, die haben gemerkt, dass der Stuff Geld macht.
Ich sag ja schon seit Jahren, der einzigen Plattform, der ich es zugetraut hätte,
einen Twitch-Kontakt zu machen, der mir das Geld macht.
Und den Konkurrenten zu machen, mit halt sowas included, wäre Pornhub gewesen.
Aber gut, anscheinend hat sich Twitch jetzt gedacht.
Who cares? Auf geht's.
Ja, kannst du machen.
Kannst du machen.
Alter, da geht's aber zu sehr.
Okay, auf der anderen Seite...
Ich mein...
Das ist jetzt erstmal groß im Hype.
Mal gucken, wie das in ein paar Wochen aussieht.
Es wird sich da sicherlich die ein oder anderen Streamer-Sachen etablieren.
Frag mich, was da alles erlaubt.
Muss es wirklich Art sein?
Also, darf es nur...
Muss es gemaltes Zeug oder computergeneriertes Zeug oder 3D-Grafiken sein?
Oder können da demnächst die Leute auch Booba-Streams machen?
Direkt gebannt?
Wo ist das Problem?
Steh ich nicht.
Außer, dass dann irgendwelche Religionsleute triggert sind.
Aber da haben sie Pech, wenn sie sich von sowas triggern lassen.
Also, furry Boobas darfst du malen, oder wie?
Twerk, twerk, twerk.
Ich kann das nicht mal aussprechen.
Also, mit dem Popo wagern die Streams sind erlaubt.
Okay, es muss artistisch sein.
Also, sprich, wenn sich da jetzt eine nackig vor die Kamera legt
und man alles sieht, dann muss auf dem Bein oder so irgendein Anime-Bild sein.
Und so, dann ist das dann artistisch.
Oder, oder wie ist das?
Kunst ist Kunst.
Leug, danke für den Sub.
Ach ja.
Wisst ihr, ich find's ja eigentlich nicht schlimm.
Ich find's so lustig, dass sie die ganze Zeit so super auf safe gemacht haben.
Und, wie gesagt, sogar Leute gebannt haben, die irgendwie ihr Only-Fans-Profil verlinkt haben.
Oder teilweise über den Umweg von einem Linked-Tree ihr Only-Profil.
Ganz merkwürdiges Zeug.
Und jetzt auf einmal...
Strippen ist auch artistisch.
Ah ja?
Ich geh mal davon aus, die Grenzen werden fließend sein.
Die haben gemerkt, dass das Kohle bringt.
Ich mein, ohne Scheiß.
Only-Fans flutscht.
Pornhub flutscht die Kohle.
Das hat, wollte ich, bei Twitch soll's jetzt auch flutschen.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Also, ich hab, ich hab mir diese neuen Regeln nicht angeguckt.
Mir war das gar nicht bewusst.
Ich war zu sehr im MMO-Kreisel-Crind, dass da überhaupt, dass ich das mitbekommen hätte.
Aber mich, mich wundert's, also, mich wundert nicht, dass das Kohle bringt.
Mich, mich wundert's nur, dass die auf einmal so umgeschwenkt sind von, ähm, ja, wir stören uns irgendwie an allem.
Aber.
Also, ich, also, ich mein, was ich ja, was ich mir noch eher überlegt hätte, ich mein, das sind ja, letztendlich sind das ja Amis.
Ich hätt mir gedacht, die machen, also, bevor die, bevor sowas erlaubt ist, sind eher, äh, äh, Firing-Range-Waffen-Shooting-Dinger erlaubt oder so.
Hell yeah, oder, oder sowas.
Wobei, ist das, vielleicht ist das sogar mittlerweile erlaubt.
Ich weiß nicht, geht, darf man Waffen-Streams machen auf Twitch?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich hab kein Only-Fans-Profil, nur Fansly.
Nur Fansly.
Naja, gut, aber, um jetzt mal vom aktuellen, vom aktuellen Twitch-Meta, von dem ich nichts mitbekommen habe, wegzukommen, gucken wir uns mal ein paar Stellenanzeigen an.
Ich, ich muss, ich muss euch jetzt, ich muss euch doch noch ne Story erzählen.
MickDiät, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich muss euch, ich muss euch doch noch ne Story erzählen, und zwar hier bei mir in Frankfurt um die Ecke, in Offenbach.
Ich muss jetzt aufpassen.
Dass ich nicht die Webseiten dazu erzähle.
Nopsi, danke für den Sub.
Sonst, sonst ist, könnte es wirklich Monkatos werden.
Weiß, weiß man nicht, ob man überhaupt solche Seiten hier dann erwähnen darf.
Zumindest, äh, hier in Offenbach, bei, bei mir um die Ecke, da gibt es so ne Werbeagentur, nennen die sich, glaube ich, offiziell.
Die sind aber nicht so ne 0815-Werbeagentur, wie man sich das vorstellt, sondern letztendlich betreiben die ein paar Pornoseiten, ja.
Und ich kenne jemanden, der dort...
Mal als, als Feezy die Ausbildung angefangen hat, aber aufgehört hat.
Und, äh, eine Mit-Azubine aus der Berufsschule, die hat da drei Jahre ihre Ausbildung gemacht.
Und Leute...
Also, ich, ich meine ja nur, weil es irgendwie gerade zum aktuellen Twitch-Meta passt.
Aber was die da für Dinger erzählt hat, also, zum Beispiel hat sie erzählt, dass es total viele Code-Wörter gibt bei diesen Seiten.
Also, zum Beispiel haben die eine Seite...
Also, du musstest dir damals Räumlichkeiten mieten für, äh, ja, so Webcam-Shows und solche Geschichten.
Und, ähm, das wurde dann irgendwie...
Ich krieg's nicht mehr ganz zusammen.
Das wurde dann immer mit irgendwelchen Code-Wörtern versehen, dass du wusstest, quasi, welche abartigen Sachen dort gemacht werden können.
Ganz weird-champ-Shit, was sie erzählt hat.
Und heute...
Um jetzt mal den, den, den Bogen zu schlagen.
Heute machen die so einen auf super-seriös.
Dabei haben sie die ganzen Seiten immer noch laufen.
Das hat mich einfach ein bisschen jetzt an Twitch erinnert, weil Twitch hat die ganze Zeit auch so auf super-seriös gemacht.
Äh, irgendwelche Porn-Bilder machen sich halt nicht gut auf der Seiten...
Auf der, auf der Seite.
Family-Friendly geht besser, aber lässt trotzdem die Kohle nicht liegen.
Ja, die, die haben's nur umgedreht gemacht.
Diese Werbeagentur.
Die haben, die haben's nur umgedreht gemacht.
Die haben früher Porn-Zeug gemacht.
Machen's heute immer noch.
Aber auf ihrer Homepage...
Ist das alles super, super legit und Werbeagentur mittlerweile.
Keine, keine Spur mehr von diesem ganzen Zeug.
Ja, und zumindest, was ich auch gehört habe von dem Laden, ist, dass der Chef ein richtiger Spaß sein muss.
Der muss auch ab und zu ins Büro reinkommen, wenn er hört, dass die Leute einen Witz gemacht haben und lachen.
Und da muss der wohl die Tür aufmachen oder reinschreien.
Wird hier gelacht oder gearbeitet.
Das hat sie mir eins zu eins so erzählt.
Shit.
Irgendjemand macht einen Witz, die Leute lachen.
Chef reißt die Tür auf und schreit rein.
Wird hier gelacht oder gearbeitet.
Also, netter Laden dort zu arbeiten anscheinend.
Ja, ja.
Okay, dann.
Updates und so sind durch.
Dann fangen wir doch mal an zu gucken, würde ich sagen.
Wird hier gelacht oder...
Das müsste man eigentlich als Antwort sagen.
Ja, gelacht.
Das geht nicht.
Ja, nee, da kenn ich, da kenn ich niemand.
Da kenn ich niemand, wie gesagt.
Ich kenn bloß...
Zwei Leute von dieser Werbeagentur in Offenbach.
Stimmt.
Außerdem wird bei uns natürlich nicht gelacht.
Bei uns wird nur gekeckt.
Vielleicht auch keckdoublejude.
Bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Manchmal reicht gekeckt nicht mehr aus.
So, dann fangen wir mal an.
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen von links nach rechts an.
Nee, Sony interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Was?
Was zum...
Was ist denn das?
Chat.
Ist das ein Chrome-Feature oder ist das ein Windows-Feature?
Das ist ein Windows-Feature.
Ach, das ist Power-Toys?
Nee.
Was ist denn das?
Was habe ich hier überhaupt an?
Ist das Power-Toys?
Exit.
Okay.
Und jetzt ist es...
Ah, jetzt ist es weg.
Okay.
Siehste mal.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Alter, Sony, da ist da aber wirklich Flashbang.
Da ist doch Flashbang drin.
Lass uns doch mal kurz gucken, was Sony...
Boah, mein Auge, Mann.
Mein Auge.
MonkaS.
So.
Also, richtige Oldschool-Stellenanzeige hier von Sony.
Nee, normalerweise brauche ich das nicht, um die Maus zu finden.
In Spielen, wo ich die Maus nicht finde, habe ich YOLO-Maus an.
Da kann man die Maus einfach pink oder lila oder rosa oder grün oder blau oder gelb oder orange oder so färben.
Also, guck mal, es ist nicht mal ein transparentes, transparentes Logo.
Nun ja, lass uns mal gucken.
Sie suchen einen Service Reliability Engineer.
Aha.
Also.
Was, was, was, was, was möchte Sony denn haben?
PlayStation isn't just the best place to play.
Da kann man sich sicherlich drüber streiten.
Aber PC Master Race-Leute werden sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht gerade bei Sony bewerben.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, ich hätte überhaupt keine Probleme mit.
Für Sony zu arbeiten.
Ich habe auch keine Probleme mit, irgendwo, wo zu arbeiten, was ich persönlich nicht benutze.
Das juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Solange die Kohle stimmt, solange die Arbeit stimmt, solange das Umfeld stimmt, Bezahlung pünktlich ist, es ordentlich Kohle gibt, ordentliche Homeoffice-Regelungen hat, drumherum alles passt.
Ich würde sogar, ohne Scheiß, ich würde sogar für die Bahn arbeiten, wenn das alles erfüllt.
Wenn die Bahn jetzt sagt, Max, komm her.
Die Bahn ist gar nicht übel.
Ich habe tatsächlich schon einige Leute, sowohl auf Twitter, die mir dort direkt geantwortet haben, ja.
Ich hatte aber auch schon Einladungen an meine, an meine, also an die Streaming, an die YouTube-E-Mail-Adresse, die ja da steht, von jemand, der bei der Bahn am Frankfurt in diesem Bahntower oder so arbeitet und an der DB-App mitentwickelt.
Ob ich mir das nicht angucken will.
Also insofern, ich glaube, so schlecht.
So schlecht ist das gar nicht.
Ich glaube, so schlecht ist das gar nicht.
Und ich persönlich, auch wenn ich die Bahn hasse, wie sonst eigentlich nichts anderes, ich würde für die Bahn arbeiten, wenn die fett Kohle bezahlt und die Arbeitsbedingungen dort und die Arbeit gut ist.
Dass der Laden scheiße ist, werde ich nach wie vor empfinden, gehe ich mal von aus.
Aber dann kann ich wenigstens davon profitieren, dass sie kacke sind.
Ja, das kann schon.
Sag das aber mal nicht.
Ich bin übelst am Umflämen.
Ich habe eine Einladung gekriegt, ob ich mir das nicht angucken will.
Ich bin übel bei der Bahn in diesem Bahn-Dings-Tower da in Frankfurt.
Also insofern, vielleicht meinen immer noch manche, dass ich bekehrt werden kann.
Aber die einfachste Art und Weise, mich zu bekehren, dass die Bahn gut ist, ist, wenn sie einfach funktioniert.
Das ist, glaube ich, das, was die meisten Leute auch relativ schnell wieder relativ milde zur Bahn werden lässt.
Wenn es, sagen wir mal, tatsächlich 95% plus.
Funktioniert.
Ich meine, man darf man nicht vergessen, die Bahn ist, glaube ich, so ziemlich das einzige Unternehmen, was sich eigene Vorgaben setzen kann,
eigene Statistiken darüber machen kann und trotzdem die Ziele verfehlt.
Da kann man davon ausgehen, die Ziele sind in Wirklichkeit einfach noch, noch viel, viel, viel, viel, viel mehr verfehlt, als das, was da rauskommt.
Was wollt ihr mit mein Geek-Chat, also ich weiß, wer das ist, das sind die Pornhub-Betreiber, wollt ihr dort arbeiten?
Weiß nicht, wie die so sind.
So, also, was will denn, was will denn Sony haben?
Also, okay, also, Playstation ist nicht nur der beste Platz, um zu spielen, es ist auch der beste Platz in der Welt, ne, steht nicht da, äh, der beste Platz, um da zu arbeiten.
Also, sie sind ganz furchtbar toll, im Prinzip ist es die 0815-Stellenbeschreibung schlechthin am Anfang, äh, bla, bla, bla, sie sind ganz toll, sie sind noch viel toller.
Sie suchen einen Service Reliability Engineer in Berlin.
Da hätte ich schon mal gedacht.
Da hätte ich schon mal gar keinen Bock drauf auf Berlin, Alter.
Leute, also, ich bin Frankfurt und Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof gewöhnt und eigentlich müsste man davon ausgehen, fast jede Stadt, fast jede Stadt ist besser als Frankfurt.
In der Ecke, Frankfurt drum herum ist vollkommen in Ordnung, Leute.
Also lasst euch nicht so sehr Chebaden vor meinem Geschwätz teilweise oder hier subreddit Frankfurt.
Frankfurt ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Solang's nicht Bahnhofsviertel und umso, umso mehr mein Haupt-, Hauptbahnhof.
Kommt ist.
Es ist, es ist, ansonsten drum herum gibt's super, ist das ganz gar nicht übel in Frankfurt.
So, aber ehrlich gesagt, was ich bisher von Berlin gesehen hab, hat mir noch weniger gefallen.
Also, ich kann's, ich kann das gar nicht so richtig, richtig in Worte, also das, meine erste, meine erste Erfahrung am Berliner Hauptbahnhof war irgendein Penner, also ich bin rausgekommen aus dem, aus dem, was ist denn das, der vordere Eing-, ja, keine Ahnung, der hat zwei Ausgänge, niemand blickt da durch, wo's, wo's lang geht.
Also, ich bin rausgekommen aus dem, aus dem, was ist denn das, der vordere Eing-, ja, keine Ahnung, der hat zwei Ausgänge, niemand blickt da durch, wo's, wo's lang geht.
Das erste, was ich hatte ist ein Penner, der mir ins Gesicht gewusst hat, direkt am Haupt-, an einem der beiden Ausgänge, an beiden der großen Ausgänge.
Habe ich mir gleich gedacht, ey, ist ja wie in Frankfurt, aber dann alles drum herum, irgendwie hat, mir hat Berlin so überhaupt gar nicht gefallen.
Ja, das ist doch nicht mal der Berliner Dialekt, das ist zwar auch irgendwie cringe, aber das denken die von Hessisch und Bayrisch auch.
Also, es gab ja mal vor Jahren so eine Umfrage, was der sexiest und unsexiest Dialekt ist.
Unsexiest Dialekt hat Sächsisch, glaube ich, gewonnen und Sächsisch, glaube ich, Bayrisch.
Da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, für mich ist definitiv Sächsisch nicht der unsexiest Dialekt.
Also, was ich überhaupt nicht abkann, ist so diesen Berliner Dialekt.
Ich hab dit und sowas. Das ist so schrecklich, man.
Das kann ich mir nicht geben, ne.
Ja, dufte, genau.
Sächsisch finde ich gar nicht so schlimm.
Nur eine Sache, warum machen sie im Osten alle nü?
Nü?
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber vielleicht beobachten.
Vielleicht bin ich da auch vorbelastet, dadurch, dass ich früher täglich mehrere Stunden mit dem Carsten und dem Frasier gelabert habe.
Wobei die beide ja eigentlich kaum krassen Sächsisch Dialekt haben.
Dass ich das jetzt nicht so sehe.
Aber ich finde den Berliner Dialekt viel schlimmer.
Also, zumindest, was wollen sie haben?
Sie wollen einen Service Reliability Engineer in Berlin.
Okay, was macht man denn bei Sony?
Was macht man denn bei Sony?
Also, man spielt eine wichtige Rolle.
Oh, das ist immer so schwierig, so anstrengend, dieses Business-Zeug zu lesen.
Okay, also man arbeitet im Cloud Gaming Team.
Okay, soll alles super stabil sein.
Es sind jetzt übrigens nicht Site Reliability Engineers, sondern Service Reliability Engineers wahrscheinlich, mehr oder weniger das Gleiche.
Also, drei hauptsächliche Sachen geht es da.
So, Overall Ownership of Production.
Ich bin lost, ich weiß nicht, was das heißen soll.
Das heißt so viel wie Produktionsverantwortung vermutlich.
Overall Ownership of Production.
Okay, Production Code Quality and Deployments.
Okay, whatever.
So.
Wenn man das hier successful sich bewerben will.
Dann muss man ein Self-Directed, muss man Self-Direct, also quasi selbstständig arbeiten, so können.
Und man muss auf mehreren Leveln Entscheidungen mit Trust, okay.
Das ist so krasses Business-Speak immer alles.
Okay, also was wollen sie?
Profession as a Linux Production Systems Engineer.
Okay, da könnte ich mich schon mal bei Sony bewerben.
Nicht, dass ich einen neuen Job suchen würde, mache ich nicht, aber immerhin.
So.
Experience Managing Large.
Scale Web Service Infrastructures.
Oh ja, das kann man sagen.
Das kann man so sagen.
Oh, das würde denen wahrscheinlich, also mein Profil zumindest für den Punkt würde denen wahrscheinlich echt gefallen.
Ähm, so.
Also, Erfahrung, was entwicklt, was Programmiersprachen angeht.
Python, Preferred.
Bash, Go, Java, C++.
Leute, ich kann einfach alles, was sie wollen.
Ich kann Python, ich kann Bash, ich kann Go, ich kann Rust, ich kann C++.
Und wenn ich mir viel Mühe gebe, kann ich auch Java.
C++ können ist immer so weit gefasst.
Es gibt niemand, der C++ wirklich kann.
So, zusätzlich.
Zusätzlich wollen sie noch, dass man sich auskennt mit mindestens drei verschiedenen von diesen Topics.
Und das erste ist Distributed Data Storage at Scale.
Okay, ich kenne mich mit Ceph aus, das ist okay.
Äh, damit habe ich keinen.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist aber, das ist auch schon, das ist schon so alt, das ist schon mittlerweile kein Buzzword für.
Äh, NoSQL at Scale, MongoDB, Redis, Cassandra.
Okay.
Alles ziemlich unterschiedlich her, was, wie das eingesetzt wird.
Aber, okay.
Also, das ist ja, sagen wir mal, so eine Distributed Datenbank im Kern.
Das ist eigentlich eher so eine Memory Cache Geschichte.
Und das ist eine klassische NoSQL Datenbank, die man irgendwie clustern muss.
Gut.
Data Aggregation Technologies.
Elasticsearch und KV.
Elasticsearch kenne ich ein bisschen.
Kafka ist sowas, das musst du studiert haben, dass du da durchblickst.
Okay.
Scaling and Traditional Relationale Datenbanken, also Postgres.
Das habe ich.
Auch wenn ich selbst von SQL, ich kriege die SQL Basics hin.
Ich kann Inserts machen, ich kann Selects machen.
Ich kann was droppen im Zweifelsfall.
Ich könnte mit sehr viel Gehirnwindungen auch einen Join machen.
Aber muss ich ja auch gar nicht.
Ich muss ja den Kram nur betreiben können.
Na, das habe ich tatsächlich auch.
Das ist das, wo ich mich hier noch am ehesten sehe.
Das ist ein Thema, was mir enorm viel, also, ja, zumindest der Part, was mir enorm viel Spaß macht.
Systemüberwachung.
Gerade in der Kombination.
Das mache ich wirklich gerne.
Das mag daran liegen, dass ich in meiner Ausbildung, damals in meiner Ausbildung,
eines der ersten Sachen war, die ich gemacht habe, nämlich damals noch mit Nagios.
Brüssel Industrie, auf geht's zu Sony, let's go.
Aber die meinen,
damit bestimmt nicht nur einfach mal installiert haben.
Und Incident Management Toolsets.
Kubernetes, Kubernetes, Kubernetes, Endor, AWS.
Hä? Das passt nicht zusammen.
Kennst du PRTG?
Ja, das ist Windows Audi.
Deswegen habe ich mich damit nie näher beschäftigt.
Das ist, das ist ganz weird.
Das hier.
Ist was ganz, das hier ist ein Cloud-Anbieter.
Und wobei man, Leute, jetzt könnt ihr was lernen.
Passt mal auf.
Wenn ihr das nächste Mal glänzen wollt bei euch.
Wenn es, wenn es drum geht, wenn es drum geht, dass ihr wieder ein bisschen, dass ihr wieder ein bisschen mehr Geld kriegt.
Darkstar, danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Und, ähm, was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Mülli, auch wieder am Start.
Danke für die Prime-Subs, Leute.
Ja, also wenn ihr demnächst mehr Geld haben wollt,
dann habe ich für euch ein richtig nice Buzzword, was ihr hier anbringen könnt an der Stelle.
Wenn euch mal wieder irgendjemand erzählt,
äh, Cloud-Anbieter, AWS,
Google oder sonst was,
dann sagt ihr nicht, dann sagt ihr, das ist kein Cloud-Anbieter,
sondern das ist ein Hyperscaler.
Das ist auch ein sehr beliebtes Wort.
Hyperscaler.
Niemand kann damit so richtig was anfangen.
Die meisten Leute haben sich, glaube ich,
mittlerweile drauf geeinigt, dass Cloud-Anbieter damit gemeint sind.
Aber da müsst ihr sagen, Hyperscaler.
Nicht Hyper-Gachi, Hyperscaler.
Was zum Teufel ist ein Hyperscaler?
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist wie bei allen Buzzwords.
Ich weiß es so genau.
Aber die Leute einigen sich dann darauf
und die Mehrheit versteht da halt Cloud-Anbieter drunter.
Wir können mal gucken.
What is a Hyperscaler?
Ja.
Type of large-scale data center
that offers massive computing resources
typically in the form of Elastic...
Äh, nein, nicht wirklich.
Aber...
Das...
Ach so, die meinen damit nicht AWS.
Im Prinzip ist das Google, Azure und AWS,
und so was.
Hyperscalers are large Cloud-Service-Providers.
Na, wenn Red Hat das sagt,
dann muss das auch stimmen.
Deswegen, wenn ihr glänzen wollt demnächst,
dann sagt ihr nicht mehr Cloud-Anbieter,
sondern ihr sagt...
Leute, so müsst ihr das machen.
Ihr müsst einfach ab jetzt immer Hyperscaler sein.
Das ist doch egal,
ob Headstand ein Hyperscaler ist oder nicht.
Da kann man sich...
Da kann man sich bestimmt...
Das ist sogar besser, wenn du sagst,
da kannst du dich dann noch drüber streiten,
ob es das ist,
oder nicht.
Am besten sagt ihr einfach von heute auf morgen
nur noch Hyperscaler.
Und irgendwann,
so nach einer Woche oder so,
wenn ihr das oft genug gesagt habt,
dann kommt dann irgendwann mal einer zu euch
und sagt euch,
sag mal,
was willst du eigentlich die ganze Zeit mit Hyperscaler?
Und dann könnt ihr ihm erzählen,
wie krass ihr euch auskennt.
Nee, aber...
Also Hyperscaler ist das, ja.
Zumindest,
die zwei Sachen passen ja nicht wirklich zusammen.
Das eine ist ein Cloud-Anbieter,
und das andere ist ein...
Locker-Cluster.
Um es am möglichst allgemein zu sagen.
Ein Container-Orchestrierungs-Tool
und ein Cloud-Anbieter.
Also das passt nicht wirklich
and or AWS zusammen an der Stelle.
Software-Distribution,
Package-Management-Distribution at scale.
Das kann ja auch alles sein.
Configuration-Management.
Kenn ich mich auch mit aus.
Software-Performance-Analyse.
Gut, kommt drauf an, wie tief gehen...
Also da muss ich sagen,
ich glaube...
Also ich habe nicht vor, mich dort zu bewerben
und in Berlin schon mal gar nicht, ja.
Aber ich...
Das ist tatsächlich eine Stelle,
die passt erstaunlich gut auf mich.
Das würde denen auf jeden Fall gefallen,
was zu dem Punkt bei mir im Lebenslauf drin steht.
Ich wollte übrigens mal ein Video mit meinem Lebenslauf machen,
fällt mir da gerade noch ein.
Das würde ihnen auch gefallen.
Und ich meine, ich kann im Prinzip auch
das meiste hiervon abdecken.
Also...
Mindestens fünf Jahre habe ich.
Habe ich.
Ich habe sogar zehn Jahre Plus-Erfahrung.
Ich...
Fast 15 Jahre Plus-Erfahrung.
Strong Interpersonal Written and...
Naja gut, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Available to be scheduled in on-call rotation.
Kein Problem, mache ich.
Wenn ihr Bereitschaft ordentlich bezahlt, kein Thema.
Also wie gesagt, ich suche nichts Neues.
Ich tue jetzt nur so, als ob...
Also ich muss sagen,
rein von den Anforderungen her,
würde das für mich...
Das würde für mich tatsächlich ganz gut passen.
Also, was...
Was sind die Benefits bei Sony?
Ja, also...
Da...
Was...
Naja, gut, ich meine,
dass man...
Dass man ein Gehalt bekommt,
jeden Monat,
weiß ich nicht, ob das so ein krasser Benefit ist, oder?
Findet ihr es ein Benefit,
jeden Monat Geld zu bekommen?
Also ich...
Also ich würde sagen,
das ist eine Grundvoraussetzung,
kein Benefit.
Wenn du jetzt 26 wärst,
wenn du jetzt 26 wärst,
und versehentlich Stonks studiert hast,
würdest du eine Ausbildung in der IT anfangen,
oder würdest du wegen des Alters Stonks machen,
für den Rest deines Lebens?
Nein, ich würde eine Ausbildung in der IT anfangen.
Und willst du was wissen?
Wegen des Alters?
Ich habe meine Ausbildung auch erst mit...
Äh...
Chatge, ich kann nicht rechnen.
Mit 23 angefangen.
Und ich habe davor auch Stonks gemacht.
Ja, nicht wirklich Stonks,
aber was in die Richtung.
Und das war überhaupt nicht meins.
Das einzige...
Ich habe es schon 500 Mal erzählt,
ich weiß, Recycle Story.
Das einzige, was ich mir von meiner BWL-Ausbildung gemerkt habe,
ist, wie man die Buchhalternase macht,
und dass man linear und degressiv abschreiben kann.
Aber ich habe mich letztens belehren lassen,
degressiv abschreiben geht nicht mehr.
Also ja, würde ich machen.
Wenn du keinen Bock mehr auf Stonks hast,
dann mach das.
Hattest du eine Probezeit bei deiner neuen Arbeitsstelle,
und gibt es bei dir regelmäßige Feedback-Gespräche?
Ja.
Ich hatte eine Probezeit,
die Probezeit war...
Ich glaube, drei Monate?
Drei Monate?
Ähm...
Ne, sechs.
Oder?
Ja, sechs Monate.
Ne, sechs Monate war die Probezeit.
Sechs Monate, die ist also jetzt auch schon rum.
Und ja, es gibt auch regelmäßige Feedback-Gespräche.
Eines der Feedbacks, die ich hatte in letzter Zeit an meinen Chef,
ist, dass ich mir öfters wünschen würde,
mit ihm mal über aktuelle Sachen zu reden,
weil der ist den ganzen Tag nur am Mieten.
Und man kriegt von ihm nix mit,
und er kriegt von uns nix mit.
Das liegt aber nicht an ihm, sondern, ja,
an dem noch übertriebeneren Mietingspensum
von Führungskräften dort in der Versicherung.
Ich mein, bei mir ist 50% des Tages schon Gemiete.
Ich bin nicht seit einem Jahr da.
Ich hab am 1. April angefangen.
Ich bin seit, sag mal, ich bin seit einem Dreivierteljahr da.
Wie stehst du zum Studiengang Wirtschaftsinformatik?
Lieber Informatik oder ist das ein guter...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich kann dazu keine Tipps geben.
Ich hab selbst nicht studiert.
Das Einzige, was ich immer mitbekomme, ist,
wenn Leute Wirtschaftsinformatik studieren,
die haben meistens keinen Bock auf den höheren Matheanteil
im normalen Informatikstudium.
Ich persönlich würde mich lieber, also ich, ich persönlich,
und ich muss dazu auch sagen, ich habe nicht vor, es zu machen.
Ich sag's nur jetzt.
Also ich persönlich, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte,
zwischen BWL-Shit oder Mathe,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich lieber Mathe machen,
als BWL-Shit.
Wie stressig ist dein Job als DevOps-Engineer?
Ach, ehrlich gesagt, es geht eigentlich.
Es hat mal immer wieder Phasen, wo natürlich viel los ist.
Gerade zum Beispiel haben wir Ende, nee, Anfang,
Ende Oktober, Anfang November gegen neuer ServiceLive,
an dem ich quasi die letzten paar Monate,
quasi seit ich da bin, mitgearbeitet hab.
Da ist natürlich auch immer ein bisschen stressig,
mal kurzfristig, aber es geht.
Also ich würde sagen, es hält sich echt so gut in Grenzen,
dass die Burst-Phasen von Stress mich nicht weiter,
nicht weiter nerven.
Und dann hast du auch ein paar, paar Phasen,
wo es dann wieder ein bisschen ruhiger ist und so.
Ey, wo sind wir überhaupt stehen geblieben?
Ne, hier, bei Sony waren wir doch.
Ok, also Chat denkt, denkt ihr auch, dass es,
dass es ein Benefit ist, einmal im Monat Geld zu bekommen,
für das, dass ihr da gearbeitet habt?
Ok, es gibt ein Disclaimer.
Es gibt einen Aggressionsbonus bei Sony.
Also, dass du nicht zufällig die neue,
den neuen Playstation-Prototyp mit in die Kneipe nimmst
und dort vergisst, wie das regelmäßig komischerweise
bei iPhones passiert.
Passt nicht zum Mindset, ne?
Das, das denke ich auch.
Das richtig agile Crimeset, High-Performer-Mindset
arbeitet auch kostenlos, solange die Vision stimmt.
Es gibt eine Unfallversicherung?
Ist das da so gefährlich bei Sony?
Was kannst du zum, als VM empfehlen?
Was?
Es ist Berlin.
Stimmt, ich habe vergessen, es ist Berlin.
Ja doch, in Berlin würde ich auch nicht ohne
Unfallversicherung arbeiten.
Ah.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, in Berlin kannst du mal
random angepiekst werden mit irgendeinem Messer,
aber das kann in Frankfurt auch passieren.
Was meinst du?
Ars Tower Typ 94.
Was kannst du zum, als VM empfehlen?
Ist einfach das zum zu viel?
Was kannst du als VM empfehlen?
Also ich kann als Virtualisierungslösung,
ja für was denn?
Server?
Irgendwie größere Infrastruktur?
Desktop-Virtualisierung?
Also zur Desktop-Virtualisierung kann ich dir nur
VMware Workstation empfehlen.
Wie man hier sieht, da Linux, da Windows.
Du willst gerne eine VM entwickeln?
Also Desktop-Virtualisierung?
Nimm VMware Workstation.
VMware Workstation ist einfach,
finde ich, das mit Abstand angenehmste,
was du unter Windows benutzen kannst.
Ich habe so Windows auf dem Host-System
und hier VMware Workstation auf dem zweiten Desktop
mit meinem i3.
Also siehst du hier, hier ist Linux am Start
und hier ist Windows am Start.
Ja.
Auch besser als Hyper-V?
Na für Desktop-Virtualisierung auf jeden Fall.
Ok, Sony.
Was hatten wir sonst noch?
Mensch, muss mal kurz ins Discord gucken.
Auf dem zweiten,
zweiten Monitor.
Hyper-V ist End of...
Was?
Nee.
Wirklich?
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Die haben doch da richtig Attacke gemacht.
Vor nicht allzu langer Zeit.
Warum sollte das End of Life sein?
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ach ja.
Ok.
Gut, ich meine,
die haben da sehr viel,
also die haben da hart rein
investiert,
aber so wirklich groß durchgesetzt
hat sich ja auch Hyper-V nie.
Interessant.
Zumindest,
also ich muss sagen,
ich habe mit Hyper-V nie großartig,
großartig was,
was gemacht.
Aber eine Sache,
die ich wirklich cool fand,
ich habe mal ein Video gesehen,
äh,
ich,
nee,
Video ist falsch,
falsches Wort.
Ich glaube,
das war so eine Konferenz-Talk
von,
von Leuten von Microsoft,
die was über Hyper-V erzählt haben
und die hatten
für Hyper-V
ein eigenes Team Mathematiker,
die den,
ja,
Core-Source-Code von Hyper-V
auf Korrektheit verifiziert haben.
Also sie haben tatsächlich
mathematisch belegt,
dass der Programm-Code
sich so verhalten kann,
wie erwarte,
wie,
wie es erwartet wird,
beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich
haben sie es umgedreht bewiesen,
dass er sich nicht
anders verhalten kann.
Ich meine,
vielleicht bringt es auch was.
Seriously,
das fällt mir jetzt gerade so ein,
wie oft,
wie viele
große Sicherheitslücken
in Hyper-V
fallen euch ein
die letzten Jahre?
Mir ehrlich gesagt
so gut wie gar keine.
Auf der anderen Seite
muss ich aber auch sagen,
mir fallen auch keine
riesengroßen
VMware-Sicherheitslücken
in den letzten Jahren ein.
Könnte das
mit meinem Server
eventuell
in den CPU-Shares liegen?
Ich weiß nicht,
was du machst.
Du hast immer noch nicht gesagt,
was du machst,
oder hast du es geschrieben?
Ich weiß nicht,
was du machst.
Du hast immer noch nicht gesagt,
was du machst,
oder hast du es geschrieben?
Ich weiß nicht,
was du machst.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
Ich kann nichts dazu sagen,
bevor du ein bisschen
mehr erklärst,
was du machst.
Auf Discord.
Ich kann...
Hä?
Okay.
Ich kann dir nicht folgen.
Was ist auf Discord?
Geck,
mate.
Also,
wo ich eben gesagt habe,
ich muss mal
auf den Discord gucken,
heißt nicht,
dass ich irgendwas gesehen habe,
was bei mir im Discord
geschrieben wird.
Ich wollte Private Messages
gucken.
Okay.
Mir war ein paar Sony
stehen geblieben.
Okay.
Aha.
Dann...
Dann lasst uns doch da
kurz reingucken.
Nee,
nee.
Ich bin nicht durch.
Mach ein Screenshot,
post es hier.
Maya TV.
Ich habe echt absolut
keine Ahnung,
was du meinst.
So.
Also,
wir sind bei Sony
stehen geblieben.
Also,
man bekommt...
Ja,
gut.
Man arbeitet in Berlin.
Natürlich muss es
eine Unfallversicherung geben.
Flexibles Arbeiten.
Can work from home
in agreement
with the manager.
Das ist halt auch
so,
finde ich immer gut,
wenn sie das reinschreiben,
dass das prinzipiell erwähnt...
Das...
Das Ding ist,
dass er ganz
entscheidend
noch nicht mal unbedingt
vom Manager ab,
sondern
von der gesamten
Kultur drumherum.
Weil
die Manager
machen das,
was quasi
ja,
so,
so vorge...
vorgegeben
beziehungsweise
so
etabliert
ist
im Endeffekt.
Also,
das hört sich für mich
nicht so an,
als sagen die jetzt
Ey,
easy,
bleib mal kurz,
bleib mal 80% der Zeit
daheim.
Aha.
Okay,
was haben wir hier?
Das ist ein Server,
der macht...
Also,
sonderlich ausgelastet
sieht er nicht aus.
Aber was soll man jetzt
anhand...
Was soll man daran
jetzt erkennen?
Also,
Screenshot
von der CPU Auslastung,
dass die CPU Auslastung
nicht sonderlich hoch ist.
Also,
so kann man da nichts mitmachen.
Wie viele Tabs offen?
Naja,
ich würde mal sagen
so 100 oder sowas.
Vielleicht.
Die Dienste.
Ja.
Und?
Sieht,
sieht,
sieht
normal aus.
Warum Chromium
anstatt
Firefox?
Warum nicht Chromium,
Chrome und Firefox?
So,
dann gibt es noch
noch
oder so. 40 Euro im Monat.
Hui, Sony, da geht's aber ab.
Christmas Closer Days.
Da wo man wahrscheinlich dann seinen Urlaub
nehmen muss oder sowas.
Long Time Service Award.
Na geil. Free Softdrinks.
Koffee. Ah.
Obstteller.
Ganz wichtig.
Vermögenswirksame Leistung.
Das meinte ich doch. Wie hab ich's gerade genannt?
Das meinte ich. Vermögenswirksame Leistung.
Oh, guck mal.
Guck mal. Es gibt ein Playstation Plus
mit Membership.
Na, dafür
kann man schon mal ein bisschen auf Gehalt
verzichten, ne?
Das meinte ich.
Okay. Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Alter.
Ich, also.
Mach mal langsam.
Mach mal langsam mit Posten.
Du musst
schon etwas
mehr schreiben.
Was genau das Problem ist
und was Sache ist. Das sind irgendwelche
random Schnipsel, die überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben.
Das ist Docker.
Was ist Docker?
Willst du mich veräppeln oder
ist das irgendwie Chebathe oder?
Ich hab absolut nicht den leisesten
Schimmer, was du willst.
Ich glaube, da trau... Glaube ich auch
mittlerweile.
Ja.
Ups.
Das ist das Falsche. Nein, das ist auch das Falsche.
Eigentlich wollte ich das Chebathe machen.
Eigentlich...
Eigentlich wollte ich den ja machen.
Richtig hartes Chebathe.
Also ist natürlich die Frage,
wie viel Geld Sony bietet.
Nur weil es
Sony ist, heißt es nicht zwangsläufig,
dass es viel Kohle gibt, ja?
Was haben wir hier unten noch?
Ja, okay.
Alles klar.
Also.
Ich hab seriously keinen Bock
in Berlin zu arbeiten, aber
ich glaube, dass
denen tatsächlich mein Lebenslauf hierfür
ganz gut gefallen würde.
Weil ich erfülle, bis auf so eine
Kleinigkeit hier, ich erfülle einfach
alles, was die haben wollen.
Okay, da kann man sich
drüber streiten, ja?
Aber ansonsten, ich hab sogar noch mehr,
als die haben wollen.
Sowohl hier, als auch hier, als auch hier.
Also ich glaube, Sony ist...
Mein Lebenslauf würde Sony, glaube ich, in dem Fall tatsächlich gut gefallen.
Aber ich werd mich nicht bewerben,
weil ich such keinen Job.
So, next. Was haben wir sonst noch?
Ach, Leute, wenn ihr irgendwas habt,
und falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab, ne?
Ähm, könnt ihr ruhig reinschicken, wir gucken uns das dann
alles heute Abend an.
Nur mal, so, mal so, falls ich
Subscriptions übersehen hab, ne? Ich guck jetzt grad
nochmal rein. Mülli ist am Start,
DarkSide ist am Start, Nobsi,
MacDiät, Loki, Mr.
Moogame.
Da hatten wir noch Arnab und Marty McFly
vor zwei Tagen.
Dankeschön für die Subs, Leute. Massive Subscriptions
hier. Pog.
Nice.
So.
Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Moin, Noah.
Also, so, fangen wir
von links nach rechts an. Das sollte ich mir auch angucken,
hat einer gepostet. Also, wir
akzeptieren das. Wir werden erstmal
richtig, oh, geblendet.
Was haben wir denn
hier? Ein Plattform-Engineer
GN?
Jetzt hört's bei mir aber auf mit den Abkürzungen.
Gender Neutral?
Warum ist das
überhaupt ein Thema?
Ich mein, who cares?
Ob's ein Typ ist
oder nicht?
Oder ein Fahrrad
oder sonst was?
Ich, ganz ehrlich, würde ich
jemand suchen,
okay, es sei denn, es ist
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben,
das zu machen, ja.
Ich würde mir alle geeigneten
Kandidaten angucken
und mir wär es scheißegal,
als was sie sich
identifizieren. Hauptsache, sie haben's
technisch drauf. Es ist mir vollkommen
wurscht. Die können sich als
Achterbahn identifizieren oder
als Mann, als Frau, als
was es noch
da für 28 verschiedene Sachen
mittlerweile gibt. Das wäre mir vollkommen egal.
Solange die Ahnung haben von dem, was sie machen,
erregt sie langweilig für den Sub.
Weil, ich mein, seriously,
was juckt's mich? Solange die gut sind
in ihrem Job, was juckt's mich?
Das ist ja keine Partnervermittlung. Mir ist wurscht,
als was die Leute sich identifizieren.
Das können die für sich machen.
Das geht mich als Arbeitgeber
doch eigentlich auch gar nix an.
Und was, und was sind
die anderen 3% Striker95?
Da fehlt, da fehlt ein bisschen was.
91,
96,
97, was sind die verbleibenden 3%?
Also,
was, äh,
Powercloud, von denen hab ich noch nie was gehört.
Also, was machen die denn?
Hört sich ein bisschen an ein Elektroauto an.
Was ist das?
Ah, der Energiewende.
Okay.
3% keine Angabe. Aha.
Also, seit 2012 gestalten wir als
IT-Unternehmen gemeinsam
mit unseren Kunden
und Partnern, okay, bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla
Okay, sie suchen einen Plattform-Engineer.
Deine Mission.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube, das einfachste mittlerweile wäre
tatsächlich, wenn man diesen ganzen
Krempel einfach weglassen würde.
Dann kannst du auch nichts falsch machen.
So, also,
bist du bereit,
dich einem Team
von Technologie-Experten
anzuschließen und an
Cloud-Infrastrukturen und Anwendungs-Architekturen
mitzuarbeiten?
Wenn ihr wollt
und es ordentlich bezahlt,
why not?
Ich mein, es ist im Prinzip genau das,
was ich aktuell mache, ja.
Als, ach hier, okay, hier nennt sich
zur Abwechslung mal Sideline.
Mal Side Reliability Engineer.
Was für ein Begriff ist, der sich immer mehr
durchsetzt?
Das wär auch geil. Stellt euch mal
vor,
jetzt stellt euch mal vor,
stellt euch mal vor, ihr bewerbt euch da
über diese, über die Homepage, ja.
Ihr seid im ersten,
im ersten Online-Teams-Call
und die machen so auf
Motivation und fragen euch,
und, Herr Bewerber, sind sie bereit,
sich einem Team von Technologie-Experten
anzuschließen? An Cloud-Infrastrukturen?
An Anwendungs-Architektur mitzuarbeiten?
Und du sagst einfach,
nein, cack-leaf.
Aber du musst es genau so sagen.
Du sagst, nein, cack-leaf.
Und dann
musst du den Call wählen.
Wichtig ist jetzt das Emote dahinter.
Aber das Emote ausgesprochen, nein,
cack-leaf. Dann sind sie erstmal
verwirrt und wissen nicht, was cack-leaf ist.
Und denken dann erst, Teams hatte irgendeine
Verbindungsstörung oder sowas.
Cack-leaf.
Oder noch besser,
du sagst,
nein, cack-leaf,
gehst aus dem Bild raus
und dann springst du zurück auf den Schuh
und sagst, she baited.
Okay, da bist du schon mal komplett durchgefallen
wahrscheinlich. Es sei denn,
das sind Twitch-Emote-Enjoyer.
Man kann doch in Teams
auch GIFs posten. Stimmt.
Dann sagst du einfach, nein, postest
cack-leaf als GIF.
Halbe ApoRed-Prank.
Ja.
Cack-leaf.
Also, als Site-Reliability-Engineer
bist du Vordenker
bei der Entwicklung und Implementierung von
DevOps-Prozessen in Cloud-Umgebung und Container.
Das ist, da sehe ich mich, genau
mein, äh, ist das
Metier? Oder wie sagt
man da?
Genau mein Bereich.
Du automatisierst Continuous Integration
und Continuous Delivery
bis zum Gehtnichtmehr und behebst Live-Probleme
und sicherlich lässt du unsere Kunden
keine Ausfälle erleben. Ey,
ehrlich gesagt, ich finde, das passt,
würde für mich auch ganz gut passen, ja.
Das ist genau so mein Ding hier, aber,
ne, also, ich muss das halt immer nur hunderttausendmal
sagen, weil sonst die Frage kommt, nein, ich such nicht schon
wieder was. Aber ich versetz mich mal
immer so in die
Rolle rein, dass ich was suche.
Normalerweise sind ja
diese ganzen Sachen immer super cringe
geschrieben. Das hier geht, das spricht mich
sogar teilweise irgendwie ein bisschen an.
Mein Milieu?
Mein Hood, sozusagen.
Was braucht,
wo brauchen wir dich? An diesen Standorten
oder Remote innerhalb Deutschlands kannst du
unser Team verstärken. Aachen,
schon wieder Berlin, Mann!
Keckleaf!
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Deine Aufgabenbereiche, okay, was
haben wir?
Analysierst, okay, die sind in AWS, also
man baut Cloud-Infrastruktur
auf. Du entwickelst unser
internes Plattform-Tool
weiter, welches den
Teams die Möglichkeit gibt,
ihren Dienst einmal selbst zu gestalten.
Okay.
Naja, mein, ist
historisch gewachsen, deswegen mit
PHP. So, du
designst und implementierst DevOps-Prozesse
in Cloud-Umgebung sowie Container-Technologien
AWS, Azure, Docker.
Okay. Du entwickelst
und verbesserst die
Continuous Integration und Continuous Delivery
Automatisierung weiter.
Das passt eigentlich alles ganz gut, ja.
Chat, wie auch immer das gepostet ist,
habt ihr das gepostet, weil ihr euch
da vielleicht bewerben wollt?
Na, ich würde nicht sagen, dass
das ein Fehler ist. Ich würde sagen, die meinen tatsächlich
beide Cloud-Anbieter an der Stelle.
Du analysierst und bebst Störungen im Live-Betrieb
und stellst sicher, dass unsere Kunden nicht von
Auswahl betroffen sind. Du arbeitest
eng. Die haben dich abgelehnt, okay.
Naja. Hätte ja
sein können, dass du dich da bewerben wolltest.
Wusste ich ja nicht.
Wer nutzt zwei unterschiedliche Cloud-Anbieter?
Da kenne ich tatsächlich einige, die das
machen. Aber da ist es meistens
hauptsächlich Azure plus
X. Und X ist dann entweder
AWS oder Google.
Und es ist meistens so, dass
viele Azure Active Directory
benutzen.
Und dann vieles von anderen Cloud-Anbietern.
Aber auch von Azure.
Aber ich habe mich ja
belehren lassen. Chat, ihr müsst mir mal
auf die Sprünge helfen. Das heißt ja nicht mehr
Azure Active Directory,
sondern es heißt jetzt,
wer weiß es, Entra.
Es ist
so dumm alles
bei Microsoft. Weißt du,
Azure Active Directory.
Jeder kennt Azure Active Directory.
Jeder kennt Azure. Also
Azure Active Directory.
Voll und ganz easy Bezeichnung.
Konnte sich jeder merken.
Entra
kann sich keiner merken.
Ich werde mir das nie, ich brauche ewig,
bis ich das im Kopf habe.
Ich meine, es sagt doch auch, Chat,
sagt ihr Office 365?
Oder Microsoft 365?
Oder
sagt ihr einfach nur Office?
Wie seit jeher?
Also die meisten Leute, die ich kenne, sagen tatsächlich
einfach nur Office.
Die meisten Leute sagen einfach nur Office.
Oder Office 365.
Aber Microsoft 365 sagt
mir so gut gar keiner. Ja, das sage ich
auch.
Aber ihr kennt ja meine Meinung,
was Office Produkte angeht.
Aus meiner Sicht hat das eigentlich alles gar keine
Daseinsberechtigung, bis auf Excel.
Und ich verwende es auch nicht.
Kannst du GitHub
Pull Requests bewerten und
sagen, ob man cool ist oder nicht cool?
Schick her. Habe ich noch nie gemacht
und ich weiß nicht, ob ich den coolen Faktor eines
GitHub Pull Requests ordentlich
bewerten kann. Aber
ich kann es ja mal probieren.
Möglich, aber wusste sofort, was es ist.
Hey, ich benötige eure
Hilfe. Ich mache gerade ein Praktikum
in einem großen Systemhaus und habe
ein Ausbildungsangebot bekommen, aber das Team
ist jetzt nicht das Beste.
Also, wenn du von Anfang an weißt, dass es ein
scheiß Laden ist,
dann würde ich da keine Ausbildung
machen. Es sei denn,
du musst irgendwie...
Ist das für dieses oder für nächstes Jahr?
Weil dieses Jahr ist eigentlich schon gelaufen.
Weil wenn das für nächstes Jahr
ist, dann würde ich sagen, guck, ob du nicht
was anderes findest. Auf der anderen Seite
hier weißt du wenigstens, was kacke ist, weil
du schon Einblicke hattest. Aber ganz ehrlich,
wenn man schon kacke
findet, bevor man dort überhaupt
anfängt, dann ist die Chance
hoch, dass man da nicht glücklich wird.
Für nächstes Jahr. Dann probier lieber nochmal
woanders was zu finden.
Dann musst du dich ja auch nicht innerhalb der
nächsten 1-2 Wochen entscheiden.
Das hat ja wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Zeit.
Dann würde ich lieber mal rumgucken und
und vielleicht
findest du irgendwas anderes, was dir mehr
zusagt. Also, ganz ehrlich,
es gibt ja immer... Wisst ihr, welchen Spruch ich
überhaupt nicht mag? Das ist diese
Geschichte von Ausbildungsjahre
sind keine Herrenjahre.
Das ist so der mega...
Gibt es einen Spruch, der mehr Boomer ist
als der? Ich finde, das
ist der boomerigste Spruch
überhaupt.
Das ist so schlimm.
Also, ich mein,
natürlich,
natürlich kannst du in deiner Ausbildung
nicht der nächste Abteilungsleiter
sein, ja? Das ist schon
klar. Was der Spruch
bedeuten soll, ich glaube, das ist
immer kontextabhängig.
Aber im Prinzip soll das so viel heißen,
wie in der Ausbildung muss man halt auch
durch viel
Mist aushalten, weil
die jetzigen Ausbilder... Du musst
einstecken können, weil die jetzigen Ausbilder
mussten das in ihrer Ausbildungszeit auch.
Ich finde das komplett verkehrt, den Ansatz.
Was ist das für eine Welt,
wo du deine Auszubildenden scheiße
behandelst, nur weil du selbst in der Ausbildung
scheiße behandelt wurdest?
Was ist das für eine bescheuerte Denkweise?
Und dann muss man sich
noch beschweren und sagen,
ah, aber die jungen Leute, die wollen
alle nichts mehr arbeiten und wir finden auch
überhaupt keine mehr. Und die Azubis haben
ja einen viel zu hohen Anspruch und was auch immer.
Also, das ist echt richtig, richtig
pepega.
Ich überlege mich auf eine IT-Managerstelle
zu bewerben,
obwohl ich in dem geforderten Bereich nur die praktische
Erfahrung als Admin habe. Was meinst du,
kann das gut gehen?
Ehrlich gesagt, wenn du
gar keine Erfahrung in dem Bereich hast,
würde das wahrscheinlich nicht
für die
Leute, die
das approven,
sprechen,
wenn sie dich da ins kalte Wasser werfen,
ohne jegliche Vorbereitung.
Ich denke, sinnvoller wäre es, an der Stelle
zu sagen, okay, wir
sehen, also dass dein Chef sagt,
okay, Soso, ich sehe, du möchtest dich
gerne in eine Management-Richtung weiterentwickeln,
was hältst du denn davon,
wenn du mal ein paar
Inhouse
Kurse dafür besuchst,
oder dich damit erst mal ein bisschen drauf
vorbereitest, bevor du von heute auf morgen
Manager wirst? Weil ich habe es ganz oft
erlebt, auch in der alten Firma, wo ich gewesen bin,
dass so dieses, man wird jetzt
vom Admin zum Manager,
eigentlich, mir
fällt ehrlich gesagt kein Fall ein, wo das
geklappt hat.
Ich meine, wenn du da Bock drauf hast, ist schon mal die
Voraussetzung, aber ich weiß nicht,
ob es ganz ohne Erfahrung
die beste Entscheidung ist,
das zu machen. Ich meine, was spricht
denn dagegen, dass du mal, ohne dass
du jetzt von Admin zu
Manager wirst, mal ein bisschen
dir das anguckst. Du kannst das ja mal irgendwo als
Vertretung machen, du kannst ja mal gucken
beispielsweise, dass du in
irgendeinem Projekt mitarbeitest,
vielleicht auch irgendwie den kleinen Teilbereich
verantwortest, was auch immer, bevor du
zu einer kompletten Manager-Stelle wechselst.
Weil wenn du jetzt,
wenn dir das hier gefällt,
dann ist die Chance wahrscheinlich sehr
hoch, dass dir eine komplette Manager-Stelle
nicht gefällt. Es mag sicherlich
die ein oder anderen Admins geben, die gute
Manager sind, aber meistens
ist es so, würde ich jetzt einfach
mal behaupten, dass ein Großteil der guten Admins
nicht gute Manager sind und
noch ein viel größerer Teil der Manager keine
guten Admins sind. Oder
ne, nimmt sich wahrscheinlich nichts. Also ich weiß
nicht, ob so eine... Ich kann nur
immer von mir sprechen, ich kenne dich nicht, aber
ich weiß, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das eine gute
Idee ist. Also wenn du
sagst, ich will das machen, dann würde ich
nicht sagen, ich springe jetzt von heute auf morgen
ins kalte Wasser. Und ganz ehrlich, wenn ich
dein Chef wäre, würde ich
dich auch nicht
da vorschlagen für die Stelle,
wenn ich wüsste, dass du hast überhaupt keine Erfahrung
und je nachdem,
ich meine, würde ich dich besser kennen.
Also dann würde ich wahrscheinlich eher zu dir sagen, hey, wie sieht's aus?
Wollen wir nicht gucken, dass
wir das vielleicht mal in nächster Zeit
dir das
ermöglichen, dir das
anzugucken und dass du dich in die Richtung
entwickelst, anstelle von heute auf
morgen Manager zu werden.
Also, Polkadot
SDK, was ist das?
Polkadot muss ich immer an das...
Kennt ihr dieses gepunktete
Trikot aus der Tour de France?
Das heißt doch auch so.
Ich...
Okay, also, dann machen wir das.
Ich bewerte den Pull Request jetzt auf
Coolness, Leute. Habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich das wirklich bewerten kann, weil...
ähm...
Ach, ach, guck mal!
Ach, deswegen kam mir das
unbekannt vor.
Das habe ich doch schon mal gehört.
Ich bin ja bei uns auf der Arbeit
auch an einem Blockchain-Projekt. Ich bilde mir ein,
das habe ich tatsächlich schon mal irgendwo gehört.
Blockchain-Shit, ja.
Okay, du hast... Oh, es ist
in Rust! Na, damit steigt der Coolness-
Faktor schon mal. Ähm...
Äh... Piwoll,
ich habe eine Idee. Was hältst du
davon, wenn wir uns das jetzt zusammen angucken und dann
darf der Chat abstimmen, ob das ein
cooler PR ist oder nicht?
Also, ich finde,
der Coolness-Faktor steigt enorm,
dadurch, dass es ein Rust-Projekt ist.
Weil die richtig coolen
Leute sind blazingly fast
in Rust.
Du hast sogar Tests geedit.
Das ist noch nicer.
Blockchain
zieht es vielleicht runter? Na, ich weiß nicht.
Das ist sicherlich Ansichtssache.
Für mich nicht. Für mich ist es neutral.
Okay.
Ja, nice.
Ich finde,
also schon gut geschrieben.
So, Files changed. Jetzt
gucken wir uns mal den Rust-Code an.
Oh, der sieht auch noch voll
Rust-mäßig aus.
Guck mal hier.
Mit
Magic-Rust-Syntax.
Und Kommentaren da oben
drüber. Meine Güte, ey.
Keck, wait.
Okay, was du da machst, habe ich keine Ahnung
von. Aber es
sieht sehr Krustentier-mäßig aus.
Oh,
sind das die Tests?
Ne.
Migration?
Da hast du ganz schön Arbeit reingesteckt, oder?
Bis das alles so fertig war.
Da hast du
bestimmt ein bisschen dran gesessen.
Oder?
Also, ich finde es gut.
Ich finde, das ist ein nicer
Pull-Request. Okay.
Dann machen wir jetzt eine Abstimmung.
War das
ein cooler
Pull-Request?
Ja?
Nein?
Wir brauchen noch eine dritte dumme Antwort.
Ne, wir brauchen keine dumme Antwort.
Es gibt auch keine additional votes
mit Keksen, weil sonst geht das wieder
50-50 aus.
Okay, Chatge.
Was meint ihr?
Hat sich über einen Monat gezogen mit Feedback?
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Guck mal, man sieht ja auch hier,
da wurde auch
ein weniges hin und her geschrieben und sowas.
Hehehe.
So richtig kaltherzige
Leute wieder im Chat. Nein.
Nein, Kek-Leaf.
Alles scheiße.
Keine guten Pull-Requests. Alles kacke.
Die Rust-Hater.
Genau.
Weil du nicht verstehst,
was es ist. Ich auch nicht.
Darum geht es nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was er da genau
gemacht hat. Okay, also hier
ist es schwarz auf weiß.
Approved. Kannst du dir Screenshotten
und den Lebenslauf einfügen,
wo bloß Chat bestätigt.
Das war ein cooler Pull-Request.
Pog.
Und nicht zu sagen
Coggers.
Gut, machen wir mal weiter.
Wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Hier, beim Plattform-Engineer.
Ne, im Chat.
Wir haken jetzt erstmal
den Plattform-Engineer ab, sonst komme ich
immer hinterher.
Ne, wir müssen erstmal den Chat abhaken,
weil ansonsten bin ich so weit hinten dran.
Für wie viel Prozent mehr Gehalt
würdest du wechseln, wenn
sonst alles passt bei deiner jetzigen
Stelle?
Also, gehen wir davon aus, mir gefällt es wirklich gut
da, wo ich aktuell bin, muss ich sagen.
Also, gehen
wir von aus,
also, Tomo, gehen wir davon aus,
dass die neue Stelle
quasi mindestens auf dem
Niveau ist bei allem, wie die
alte, plus mehr Geld,
ja, weil das ist schon gut.
Also, ich mag die Leute, ich mag die
Arbeit, gerade was Cloud, diese ganze
Cloud- und Blockchain-Thematik angeht,
das ist einfach so richtig Bleeding Edge
Shit.
Ich finde die Homeoffice-Regelung gut, ich finde das Gehalt gut,
ich finde gut, dass mein
Lieblingskollege aus dem letzten Laden
mitkommen konnte und
dass wir eine Kantine haben und es gibt
jede Menge Sachen, die ich gut finde.
Also, ich habe echt keine Absichten zu wechseln.
Also, wenn man mal davon ausgeht,
dass das, also, gehen wir,
wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass es exakt
im neuen Laden so wäre,
wie jetzt, plus
mehr Geld, also, dass ich den
Aufwand und das Hin und Her und das Wechsel
und das Neueingewöhnen
auf mich nehmen würde, würde ich schon sagen,
20% mehr müssten sein.
Wenn ihr noch Blockchain-Devs sucht,
kannst du mir, mache ich, mache ich.
Erinnere mich nochmal dran
im Chat.
Ich bin nämlich gerade nicht auf der Arbeit, ich bin,
ich habe Urlaub bis 1.
Ich bin nicht, dass wir Polka.rust-Developer
suchen, aber wenn, wenn,
dann schlage ich dich vor und das Gute
ist, wenn ich dich vorschlage,
kriege ich sogar Provision.
Provision kann man es nicht nehmen. Werbe,
Werbe,
Prämie oder so.
Bei welchem Unternehmen würdest du eine Ausbildung starten,
wenn man es Richtung Cloud, keine Ahnung.
Meinen Ausbildungsbetrieb gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Also, da schon mal nicht.
Das hatten wir auch, da wo ich die Ausbildung
gemacht habe, da hatten wir teilweise
...
irgendwie Anni 50 Azubis.
Als billige Arbeitskräfte.
Meine eine Frage.
Ich habe meiner Mutter ein neues Handy gekauft
und erbarmt sich keiner der bucklingen
Verwandtschaft, ihr das Handy einzurichten
und sie will warten, bis ich
zu Besuch komme Anfang April.
Macht das irgendwelche Probleme, es so lange liegen zu lassen?
Nö.
Außer, dass du es nicht mehr umtauschen kannst.
Wobei, du hast, ach online,
die Mediamarkt, ja gut, dann, wenn es
Probleme hat, kannst du es halt nicht mehr umtauschen.
So ohne weiteres, ne.
Du kannst immer noch sagen, es ist kaputt,
innerhalb von 6 Monate und so, ja.
Aber, ist halt schwieriger.
Kann ich das nicht mal, kann ich
das nicht alleine wenigstens einschalten?
Und du sagst ihr, was du drücken musst?
Das kriegen die doch meistens hin.
Das machen wir heute nicht.
Sagt mir nix.
Wie ist deine Erfahrung mit der
Arbeitsmoral der jungen Generation?
Ist mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt,
weiß ich grad nicht.
So, jetzt haben wir
den Chat geschafft, wir machen weiter, ja.
Also, hier sind wir stehen geblieben.
Du arbeitest eng mit Softwareentwicklern,
Architekturteams, okay, das ist, ah,
du stimmst dich direkt
mit internen Stakeholdern, ah.
Ja, da werden wieder
die
Stakes geschwenkt.
Unsere Anforderungen. Also, bis jetzt
fand ich das gar nicht so übel hier.
Unsere, unsere, unsere
Anforderungen. Du hast ein abgeschlossenes Studium
in der Informatik oder Wirtschaftsinformatik.
Wie? Die,
Vergleich, nicht,
oder vergleichbare Ausbildung
gibt's nicht.
Das
wollen die trotzdem.
Weil ich mein, seriously,
who cares, wenn einer vor fünf
oder zehn Jahren
ein Wirtschaftsinformatikstudium abgeschlossen hat.
Du bist erfahren in der Programmierung mit PHP
und Frameworks for Symfony.
Da muss ich sagen,
das passt bei mir nicht. Ja, das am Anfang
hätte gut gepasst, aber das hier gar nicht.
Du konntest bereits Erfahrung
in Design Implementierung mit
Cloud Archive, ja gut, das ist natürlich sinnig
für so eine Stelle.
Wollen die jetzt eigentlich jemand, der
schon länger
Erfahrung hat oder nicht?
Das kann ich jetzt nicht so richtig
da, weil das ist,
das ist ja sehr vage, also
du konntest bereits
Erfahrung, das ist so, das ist so
große Interpretationsfrage.
Du
automatisierst lieber einmal mehr
richtig, als Dinge zweimal zu tun.
Das finde ich ist eine bescheuerte Ansicht.
Die Aussage
gibt's öfters, aber die finde ich total bescheuert.
Meusel12,
danke schön für den Sub.
Das finde ich total bescheuert.
Ach, du hast noch einen Sub
gegiftet. Pogu, dankeschön.
Die Aussage finde ich total
bescheuert. Also ich
verstehe den Hintergrund, so nach
dem Motto, wenn man jetzt
zum hundertsten Mal einen Server aufbaut, dass man
mit Ansible richtig macht und so,
da sage ich überhaupt nichts zu. Wenn man öfters
Clown-Infrastruktur hinstellt,
abreißt, das mit Terraform richtig zu machen,
ist gut. Aber wenn das was
ist, was noch in der Erprobung
ist, da macht es
oftmals keinen Sinn, so
ja, so fließend
wie das ist, da großartig
was zu automatisieren.
Und da macht man trotzdem Dinger zwei,
dreimal, ja. Also wenn man gerade
irgendwie erprobt,
oh, fällt mir jetzt gerade kein gutes Beispiel
für ein, ja, irgendeine Software,
wenn man jetzt irgendwas ausprobiert, ja, nehmen wir
doch mal, nehmen wir doch mal das,
was ich in letzter Zeit, die letzten
paar Monate auf der Arbeit ausprobiert habe, ja.
In der Google Cloud, welche
Infrastrukturkombination ist am
schnellsten für unsere Blockchain-Kisten,
ja. Da habe ich mehrfach
Linux-Kisten auf- und abgebaut,
ja. Und wisst ihr, was ich auch,
was ich da, das einzige,
was daran automatisiert war,
war ein bisschen rüber
kopiere von der alten Kiste. Ich meine,
letztendlich, ich hab die, ich hab die
noch nicht mal mit Terraform aufgebaut. Wozu?
Du klickst dreimal auf weiter,
ähm, zumal ich immer andere
Konfigurationen für die VM gebraucht habe,
ja, mal mit lokalen SSDs, mal mit
Netzwerk-Storage und sonst was. Du klickst
die VM an, dann kopierst du dir ein paar
Sachen rüber und, und,
und startest ein paar Sachen neu. Das hätte
ich automatisieren können, aber
es war auch überhaupt nicht klar, was da am Ende
rauskommen soll. Deswegen, es macht, finde
ich, und ich behaupte auch einfach mal, das
war viel weniger zeitaufwendig, als
das irgendwie jetzt zu automatisieren
an der Stelle. Ja?
Also, dem
Gedanken gebe ich prinzipiell recht,
aber
das so strikt auszulegen, finde ich
bescheuert. Und den Satz habe ich schon öfters
gehört und ich fand ihn jedes Mal bescheuert.
Es ist wie bei allem,
es muss kostennutzenmäßig
sich lohnen. Und
man kann selbst sagen, hey, und wenn man,
wenn man Sachen macht, einmal im Jahr,
für die eine
Viertelstunde dauern,
aber die zu automatisieren,
würde viel komplizierter,
also zum Beispiel, ich habe,
ich habe ein Beispiel für euch.
Eine Sache, die ich automatisiert
habe auf der alten Arbeit,
die aber zumindest fragwürdig
ist zu automatisieren.
Je nachdem, wie oft sie vorkommt.
Und zwar, es gab
bei uns,
ein Anbieter, der
hat unsere Mails, also beim alten
Arbeitgeber,
nach Spam gefiltert.
Und da sind ab und zu
E-Mails im Spam gelandet.
Und da gab es an unseren Support
ein
Task, dreimal am Tag
mussten die sich einloggen
im Webinterface von diesem
Spamfilteranbieter
und alle E-Mails freigeben, die im Spamordner
gelandet sind. Fragt nicht warum,
aber so musste das gemacht werden.
Hat spezielle Hintergründe,
warum das gemacht werden muss.
Und
haben keinerlei API gehabt
zum ansprechen. Wir haben übrigens
ein paar mal mit denen telefoniert
und ein paar mal auch, wo es darum ging, ob der Vertrag
verlängert wird und sowas, wurde auch drauf
angesprochen, Leute, warum habt ihr nicht eine API, um das
irgendwie zu automatisieren, E-Mails freigeben
und sowas. Und wisst ihr, was die Antwort war
von denen? Ah ja, das ist eine gute
Idee, da gibt es schon bei uns
einen internen Feature Request.
Und damit haben
sie sich irgendwie abspeisen lassen.
Was juckt mich als Anwender draußen, ob es
bei denen schon einen Feature Request gibt,
der Scheiß funktioniert nicht, das juckt mich doch null,
ob die da intern schon irgendeinen
Feature Request haben.
Naja, zumindest
was ich dann gemacht habe ist,
ich habe Browser
Automatisierung, mich im Land
der Browser Automatisierung
versucht. Kennt ihr Puppeteer?
Das ist ein
Fernsteuerungs Framework für Chrome.
Und da habe ich
ein Tool
gebaut, was Chrome
fernsteuern kann, und was
dann im Web Interface rumklickt
und Spam
freigibt. So, und jetzt überlegt
euch mal, man hätte
so eine Aufgabe, und das hat
einige Tage gebraucht, bis das wirklich ordentlich
funktioniert.
War das zufällig Hornets
Siegel? Nein, war es nicht. War was
anderes. Ich sage euch nicht, welcher das
war. So, und
wenn man das jetzt nur einmal im Monat
für eine Viertelstunde machen sollte,
ist halt echt fraglich,
ob sich das dann lohnt, kurz zu
automatisieren, zumal die Automatisierung
auch enorm fehleranfällig ist,
weil sobald sich die
Webseite von denen ändert, und das kam auch öfters
mal vor, musste ich
meine Automatisierung anpassen.
Also das ist halt das Ding,
kann man nicht drüber streiten. Also das
einzige, und wenn ich da,
und das auch nur privat,
also, Erfahrung haben
ist tatsächlich Cloudflare,
aber im größeren
Ziel, keine Ahnung.
Zuverlässige Sicherheit sind für dich wichtigste,
die wichtigsten Aspekte jeder Infrastruktur?
Okay.
Für mich, ganz ehrlich, wisst ihr, was ich denen
auf diese Frage sagen würde?
Für mich sind die wichtigsten
Aspekte, was für euch die wichtigsten Aspekte
sind.
Wenn ihr sagt, Performance ist der wichtigste Aspekt,
ist für mich Performance der wichtigste Aspekt.
Wenn ihr sagt, Ausfallsicherheit
ist der wichtigste Aspekt, ist das für mich
der wichtigste Aspekt. Wenn ihr sagt, es muss
möglichst billig sein, ist das
für mich der wichtigste Aspekt. Für mich
ist der wichtigste Aspekt, was für der wichtigste Aspekt
für denjenigen ist, der mich bezahlt.
Natürlich sind das wichtige
Aspekte, aber was der Schwerpunkt ist, das dürfen
die entscheiden. Und wenn ihr sagt,
zuverlässig und Sicherheit, dann ist das für mich
auch so.
Da bin ich dabei.
Linux ist für dich
das einzig wahre Serverbetriebssystem.
Ja, da bin
ich dabei. Da kann ich mich mit Internet
qualifizieren.
Ich würde sagen, Moment, ich muss
mal kurz auf die Bewerbung, auf die
Stellenanzeige von ChatGPT
zurückgreifen, weil die
trifft's hier eigentlich ganz gut.
Hey, wir suchen einen verdammt genialen
Senior Linux Engineer, der
Windows als das Scheißsystem betrachtet,
das es ist.
Da haben wir ChatGPT mal gefragt,
ob es eine Stellenanzeige generieren
kann für einen Linux-Admin,
der Windows nicht mag.
Aber davor musste man, davor musste
man ChatGPT dazu überreden,
zu fluchen.
Das macht's nämlich standardmäßig nicht.
Ja, sehr gut.
Sehr gut. Das spricht mich,
das spricht mich ja schon mal richtig
an hier. Du fühlst dich
auch im Umgang mit großen Datenbanken sicher.
Ehrlich gesagt, kommt
drauf an. Also, wenn ihr wollt, dass ich
mich da mit irgendeinem SQL
CLI-Tool connecte, oder
GUI-Tool, ist mir auch egal, und dort
irgendwelche Live-SQL-Statements
abtippe, dann nicht.
Und ich glaube, jeder,
der sich da zu sicher
fühlt bei, der hat ernsthafte
Probleme.
Das ist ein Drop-Table wie bei GitLab
vor ein paar Jahren.
Die Kommunikation auf Englisch, auch
im professionellen Kontext, stellt kein
Problem für dir. Chat.
Also,
ihr kennt meine Englisch-Exkurse
teilweise hier im Stream,
wenn's mal sein muss. Das ist
eindeutig Professional-Kontext.
Wobei man sagt,
solange sich
alle beiden Seiten Mühe geben,
funktioniert das tatsächlich ganz gut.
Kann es sein, dass
es Community-Gil
dass es Community-Gil
nicht mehr als
Emote gibt?
Chat, warum gibt es
Kom...
Hat FFZ da wieder irgendwas verkackt?
Warum geht bei mir
Community-Gil nicht? Das ist doch
ein 7TV-Emote, oder?
Ja, warum geht bei... Doch!
KekG
ging bei mir auch die ganze Zeit.
Was ist denn da los?
Warum geht KekG nicht?
KekG ist kaputt.
Ja, jetzt geht KekG.
Also, bei mir geht KekG
in meiner Vorschau auf
dem zweiten Bildschirm geht es,
aber hier geht das nicht.
Sekunde.
Nervt nicht,
was ist das hier?
Das ist ein
7TV-Emote.
Ist das vielleicht...
Ja, weiß ich echt nicht.
Schau, unlisted Emotes.
Probieren wir nochmal.
Bitte
noch einmal KekG gehen.
Nee, geht nicht.
Was ist denn hier los?
Ich weiß nicht, was es für Probleme
hat. Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich vielleicht GIF-Emotes
aus, oder?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Muss wohl schon andermal weiter gucken, was das wieder für
Schmerzen hat.
So.
Unser Tech-Stack.
Was haben wir?
Nomad! Alter, das sind die einzigen,
die ich kenne, die Nomad verwenden.
Nomad ist, wenn ich das
richtig im Kopf habe,
die
HashiCorp Kubernetes
Alternative, oder?
Glaube ich.
Ja.
Genau.
Das habe ich noch nie live im Einsatz.
Gesehen.
Terraform, ja. AWS, logisch.
Packer auch, meinetwegen.
Konsul auch. Alter, mein Headset.
Wartet mal.
So, wieder da.
So, das auch. Docker, Ansible,
Jenkins, meinetwegen PHP, Bash,
Python. Das passt alles. Aber
Nomad habe ich so noch nicht gesehen.
Ja.
Das in einem Punkt ist schon wild.
Aber, ja.
Ich könnte es auch sagen.
Timescale ist ja eigentlich Postgres.
Das ist nicht Slash.
Das ist eigentlich das gleiche.
Also, Timescale ist ein Add-on
für Postgres.
Timeseries Datenbank Add-on für
Postgres.
Unseren gesamten
Tech-Stack.
Power Cloud.
Oh, ne.
Das ist mir ein bisschen zu viel.
Shit.
Code
Zepchis. Was?
Noch nie gehört.
Hast du schon mit ASCII
Docs gemacht? Nö.
Also, ich kenne das.
Aber ich habe damit nichts
gemacht. So.
Nächstes Angebot.
Was haben wir denn
hier? Das hatten wir schon.
Stellanzeige. Oh, das ist so.
Das ist so. Ist das die Sparkasse?
Ne, markant.
Mach deine
Zukunft markant.
Ein DevOps-Engineer.
Mitgesucht. Unsere Teams sind
Offenburg, nicht Offenbach.
Wichtiger Unterschied.
Entwickeln
mit Hilfe modernster Technologie effiziente
Service-Lösung zur Digitalisierung
der Wirtschaft. Alter, wie
Business möchtest du
deinen Intro-Satz machen?
Da kann sich ja nun wirklich
gar keiner was darunter vorstellen, was die
eigentlich schreiben.
Wie Business möchte dein
Intro-Satz sein, Mann?
Nee, ordentliche Stühle gibt's
da nicht. Da sind die zu
agil für.
Wenn du deine technologischen
Skills in Projekten direkt in
die Praxis umsetzen möchtest, dann komm
in unser Scrum-Team.
GWG.
Lösung und entwickle
mit uns Services zur Erfüllung
der Regularien im Rahmen
der Geldwäsche. Ach, so
sieht's aus. Geldwäscheprävention.
Musste ich auch letztens eine Schulung zu machen.
Ist Pflicht bei uns. Ist Vorgabe.
Geldwäschepräventionsschulung.
Da weiß ich jetzt
wenigstens Bescheid, wie's geht.
Wichtig, dass man die Schulung gemacht hat.
Du bist froh, keinen Scrum mehr machen
zu müssen. Kommt immer drauf an,
wie's gemacht wird.
Solche agilen Sachen oder
eigentlich fast alle so Management-Methoden
stehen und fallen
mit den Leuten, die dabei sind.
Also auf allen Ebenen.
Unser Aufgabenprofil. Als
Teil eines agilen Teams
baust du
mithilfe moderner Cloud-Infrastrukturen
und Container-Plattformen den Grundstück unserer Projekte
und gestaltest solide und wartbare Architekturen.
Residenz-Sleeper.
Aber passt zumindest schon
einmal gut zum Titel.
Du übernimmst mit deinem Wissen und deinen Erfahrungen
eine zentrale Rolle in der Betreuung und Weiterentwicklung
unserer IT-Infrastrukturen, unserer Delivery-Prozesse,
unseres Monitors sowie mithilfe
von Cloud-Lösungen als auch On-Promise.
Die On-Premises-Software.
Die sind uncool.
Die coolen Leute sagen nur noch On-Prem.
Weil sie da einfach
geiler Cloud-Native-mäßig klingen.
Ja. Ok.
Und ich hab mal
eine Frage.
Worauf läuft denn
die On-Premises-Software?
So.
Schon bei der
Konzeptionierung und Entwicklung der Anwendung
planst du den späteren hochverfügbaren
und skalierbaren Betrieb.
Siehst du, deswegen Hyperscaler,
Leute. Ich hab's euch gesagt. Das Wort
merkt euch ohne Scheiß, wenn ihr klären solltet.
Das Wort könnt ihr überall anbringen.
Werft einfach mal regelmäßig
bei irgendwelchen Meetings das Wort
Hyperscaler rein und dann berichtet mir im Stream,
wie es angekommen ist.
Die haben ein eigenes Rechenzentrum in Offenburg.
Da hab ich gearbeitet. Nice.
Das heißt, du weißt, wie da
hyperscaled wird bei denen.
Du stellst
sicher, dass unser Service reibungslos
funktionieren. Du stehst sowohl Kunden
als auch deinen Teams stets mit lösungsorientierten
Ideen zur Seite und setzt, okay,
blablabla. Ja. Also ich mein,
das passt eigentlich schon mal ganz gut zu dem, was sie haben wollen
und dem, was sie hier schreiben. Das ist natürlich, sag mal,
sehr 0 auf 15 und bisschen trocken geschrieben,
aber das passt zumindest zusammen. Das haben wir ja auch nicht
in jeder Stellenanzeige.
Und ein Hyperscaler, korrekt. Das kann man überall
anbringen. Ich frag mich,
was der Bäcker macht, wenn man dort einen Hyperscaler
bestellt, man.
Also wenn's einen Hyperscaler
beim Bäcker zu bestellen gäbe,
dann würde der überall in Deutschland Hyperscaler
heißen, aber in Berlin hätte das Ding
wieder irgendeinen anderen Namen.
Ihr Bewerbungsprofil, Praxiserfahrung,
Kenntnisse, blablabla. Okay, also,
Technologien. GitLab,
GitLab, Jenkins,
Linux, Elk,
Grafana, oh.
Ist auch nicht unbedingt das
allerverbreitetste Elasticsearch
Matrix-Stells-Zeug.
Grafana, Azure,
bläh, mag ich nicht.
Azure DevOps,
Kubernetes, Rest.
Okay, wie
0815 soll das sein?
Rest. Irgendjemand hat gesagt,
schreibt da noch Rest rein, das ist voll technisch
und so und kommt gut an.
Passt halt so gar nicht rein
an der Stelle.
Mein Rest ist ja noch nicht mal eine Technologie
streng genommen.
So. Und
Docker. Ja, okay, das
lass ich mir gefallen.
Bereitschaft sich in neue Technologien
einbauen. Okay.
Konzeptionelle Fähigkeiten.
Bereichsübergreifendes und
prozessorientiertes Denken und
Handeln.
Wenn ihr das sagt.
Okay, da hat einer aus der Marketingabteilung
aber richtig in die
Zitatkiste gegriffen, oder?
Verwandle Neugier in Aufbruch
und Interesse in echte Initiative.
Ey, du
schickst einen Link hier im Chat und ich guck das
aber vorher auf dem zweiten Bildschirm in meiner
E-Mail, dass du keinen Mist schickst.
Mach deinen ersten Schritt in Richtung
eines Arbeitsplatzes. Okay.
Also für den Fall der Fälle, dass das jemand
geschickt hat, weil er sich dort bewerben will.
Also was ich gut finde ist,
die Basics passen schon mal. Das was sie
suchen passt gut mit dem was sie schreiben
überein. Der Rest ist aber so
sehr 0815.
Aber muss nicht schlecht sein.
Ich mein, wir können als
Bewerber so Sachen
ja nur anhand der Stellenanzeige
bewerten. Genauso wie die
uns erstmal nur anhand von irgendeinem
Lebenslauf oder so
bewerten können. Wir kennen
die ja nicht näher im Detail
und die uns auch nicht. Das heißt müssen
wir danach gehen, was wir sehen.
Das ist okay. Das ist
jetzt nicht super
würde es nicht für mich super herausstechen,
aber das kann durchaus gut sein.
Weiß es halt jetzt an der Stelle
nicht. Was ich
nice finde ist, dass sie erst gar nicht anfangen
mit ihren Benefits, wenn es keine gibt.
Ne, steht nix.
So, next.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Aha.
Ein IT Spezialist.
Im Einsatz.
IT im Einsatz.
Aber sicher, kommt zu uns ins
Team IT.
Das sieht aus, also erstens
sieht das eins zu eins aus wie ein Hemd von mir
und es könnte auch sogar meine Hand sein.
Aber an so einer Tastatur arbeite ich nicht.
Aber dieser Satz
hier oben und die Schriftart,
alles, das sieht aus wie das alte
Fachinformatiker Handbuch.
Kennt noch einer das alte?
Bessermann
Fachinformatiker
Handbuch.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ja, das geht schon eher. Aber das
alte, das alte hatte so eine Aufst...
Das passt. Das sieht von der
Schriftart und dem Ding, sieht das
total ähnlich aus.
Ist das Windows 7? Ja, komm, wie weißt
wie alt das Bild ist?
Was habt ihr? Team Magus?
Ist da was in der Richtung?
Ne, was wollt ihr?
Ach so.
Ach so, Magus.
Ach, das ist von der
Polizei.
Die Polizei Hubschrauberstaffel Bayern.
Sucht zum nächstmöglichen
Zeitraum, München Flughafen.
Ist das der, wo man in 10 Minuten und so...
Das äh...
Ist äh...
10 Minuten.
Das ist der, okay.
Ein IT-Spezialisten.
Netzwerktechnik
und Administration in
Vollzeit.
Ja, das ist Stoiber. Ich weiß.
Aber der Münchner Flughafen ist das, wo man in 10 Minuten
da ist. Direkt vom Hauptbahnhof.
Ich weiß, dass ich den Stoiber meine.
Aber der
Münchner Flughafen.
Ja, genau das. Das meine ich.
Okay, also die Polizei
Hubschrauberstaffel Bayern
sucht am Flughafen
einen IT-Spezialisten
in Netzwerktechnik...
Netzwerkadmin suchen die im Endeffekt.
Im Zuge der Einführung modernster
Polizeihubschrauber...
Okay, der Zusammenhang zwischen
Hubschraubern und Netzwerkadministration
erschließt sich mir noch nicht so
vollständig, aber das kommt jetzt ja noch.
Also, im Zuge der Einführung
modernster Polizeihubschrauber
und der damit verbundenen IT-Technik
ist die neue digitale Infrastruktur
hinsichtlich der konzeptionierten
Vernetzung zu betreuen.
Die Administration erfolgt
größtenteils allein, beziehungsweise
an einem sehr eng gefassten...
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
Ich bin alleine für die gesamte
Polizeihubschrauberstaffel zuständig.
DHCP auf Hubschrauber.
Da gibt's
TCP über Brieftauben schon ganz
neue Bedeutung.
Es ist breit gefächertes Wissen im IT.
Insbesondere im Bereich
der Hubschrauberintegrierten speziellen
EUG...
LUG-Technik
erforderlich.
Betreuung der taktischen IT...
der taktischen... Tactical...
Der taktischen
IT-Infrastruktur Polizeihubschrauberstaffel
Bayern.
Piusb... Die Abkürzung
immer, Mann!
PH Hust... PH Hust bei
Monka Tactical.
Administration der Missionscomputer
der Polizeihubschrauber. Administration
der Hubschrauber zugehörigen
Netzinfrastruktur inklusive Crown-Server
und bordeigenem Router
der Polizeihubschrauber.
Koordination mit den Vertragsunternehmen
und Abstimmung von Updates und Fortentwicklung
hinsichtlich technischer Fragen. Das mache ich alles
alleine.
Ich weiß, dass
das steht alleine, beziehungsweise
in einem sehr gefassten... Aber Leute,
bei solchen Sachen
mache ich das, was viele Arbeitgeber
mit eurer Bewerbung auch machen.
Wenn es zwei Sachen zur Auswahl gibt,
lege ich das
den schlechteren Fall aus.
Also wenn da steht, größtenteils
allein, beziehungsweise
in einem sehr eng gefassten Admin-Team,
lese ich da allein.
Koordination,
Abstimmung mit Betroffenen,
Verfahrenskoordination in
technischen Fragen.
Update Pflege der taktischen...
Die sind aber äußerst tactical.
Der taktischen IT-Infrastruktur
in Polizei...
Ich habe ein
Tactical Tomahawk letztens
gesehen auf Amazon.
Das ist so eine Axt.
Ich weiß nicht, was daran Tactical ist,
aber die war halt schwarz, so wie diese ganzen
Tactical Equipments, die es immer gibt.
Aber es war halt ein Tomahawk,
so eine Axt.
Genau, sie ist schwarz. Wahrscheinlich ist das Tactical
da dran. Genauso wie die ganzen
Tactical
Taschenlampen,
die
auf voller
Lichtstärke irgendwie 5 Minuten halten
mit der Batterie oder sowas.
Update Pflege der taktischen IT...
Okay, jetzt hatten wir es schon.
Update Pflege der taktischen IT-Infrastruktur
im Polizeihubschrauber
in Abstimmung mit dem technischen Betrieb
der taktischen
P. Hust bei...
Okay, Betreuung möglicher Schnittstellen,
Missionssoftware,
Einführung von Konzepten hinsichtlich des
Betriebs und Pflege der taktischen IT...
Infra... Da musst du schon so
auf Military Shit stehen, oder?
Infrastruktur...
P. Hust bei...
Mitwirkung im Bereich
Implementierung eines digitalen
Board-Buchs und digitale Flugzeiten-Erfassung...
Taktische Mittagspause...
Du machst Tactical Break...
Wenn schon, du machst keine Mittagspause...
Der Chopper-Gunner...
Störungsbeseitigung,
Störungsmanagement mit dem Vertrag,
und, okay...
Ich bin mal gespannt, was die...
Seriously, Leute, das wirkt für mich als
ein äußerst
verantwortungsvoller Job,
weil...
Da fliegen Leute in Hubschrauber und wenn das nicht
funktioniert, stürzen die ab.
Oder, naja, haben zumindest
Probleme, die zu Sicherheitsding...
Also, das ist... Da ist schon enorm viel Verantwortung
bei. Mal gucken, was man dafür... Was sie noch
haben wollen, okay...
Abgeschlossenes IT-Studium mit
Diplom-Ingenieur oder abgeschlossen... Achso, staatliche
Gebrü...
Zum staatlich geprüften
Fachinformatiker...
Zum was?
Ist man dann staatlich geprüft?
Also, ich meine, ich bin
Fachinformatiker, aber ich wüsste nicht, dass ich
staatlich geprüft bin.
Ach, das ist Bayern. In Bayern heißt
das so. In Bayern heißt das wahrscheinlich
einfach so, jaja...
Bevorzug mit Spezialisierung in der Fachrichtung
Systemintegration, digitale Vernetzung... Ja gut, das sind
die zwei neuen... Also, ich wollte keinen Anwendungsentwickler,
wobei, wenn er das kann...
Einschlägige Berufserfahrung gewünscht,
erweiterte Kenntnisse im Linux-Bereich...
Ah, da sehe ich mich. Demnächst
Tactical Linux-Administration,
Tactical SSH,
gute Kenntnisse in
Netzwerktechnik, Grundkenntnisse
Digitalfunk,
fundierte Kenntnisse zu
Software-Architektur,
technischer Sachverstand, sehr gute Kommunikation,
zuverlässiges und innovatives
Arbeiten...
Wisst ihr, ich glaube, eine Sache,
die dort sehr, sehr selten vorkommt,
ist innovatives
Arbeiten.
Hohes Verantwortungsbewusstsein, Teamfähigkeit...
Okay, unser Angebot, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Also,
Arbeiten in einem technisch sehr modernen Sportumfeld,
behördliches Gesundheitsmanagement,
sowie Nutzung der Sportstätten des
Flughafen Münchens.
Okay.
Da kann ich dort mal eine Runde rennen.
Vielfältiges
Verpflegungsangebot in zahlreichen Flughafen,
Mitarbeiterkantien, kostenlose Parkmöglichkeiten...
Okay, das ist ja alles nett verkehrt, ja.
Okay,
die Einstellung erfolgt in Arbeitnehmerverhältnissen
nach der Bestimmung des Tarifvertrags, öffentliches Dienst,
TVL,
die Eingruppierung richtet sich nach dem
jeweiligen persönlichen Fortschritt zu höchstens Entgeltgruppe 11.
Also, wir suchen mal TVL
11.
Ist das hier die richtige
Seite?
11.
Habe ich hier das Richtige?
Ja.
11.
Habe ich das Richtige?
Ja.
äh, nee, nee, nicht netto, nicht netto, Brutto, da musst du auch Steuern drauf bezahlen natürlich, ja, ich weiß nicht, wie es da steuermäßig aussieht, wenn du dort arbeitest, ob es da irgendwie Vorteile gibt, weil das ja was Öffentliches ist, keine Ahnung, also, wenn du so gut wie keine Steuern bezahlst, ist das vollkommen in Ordnung, wenn du halt ganz normal Steuern bezahlst, dann ist das in München jetzt eher wenig,
würde mich interessieren, was man da am Ende rauskommt, aber seriously, es sieht für München und Umgebung echt nicht viel aus, also generell würde ich sagen, mit der Berufserfahrung ist in ganz Deutschland 54k nicht sonderlich viel, also ich meine, die wollen ja mindestens, die wollen ja mindestens Leute mit 6 Jahren, äh, oder, nee, nee, okay, 3, 3, ja, aber trotzdem, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt super üppig, Moment, was, Rechner, boah,
Alter, mein Auge, ich kann sich sowas einfach posten, netto bleiben, Stufe 1, Moment, wir wollen nicht Stufe 1, wir wollen ja nicht Stufe 1 gucken, wir wollen, wir wollen Stufe, Stufe 3 gucken, macht man hier oben dann Stufe 3, nee, wo macht man hier 3, Stufe 3, Stufe 3, ja, aber Stufe 3 wollen wir doch, das ist das Maximale, was du kriegen kannst,
ach so,
ah, da ist schon, das ist das Maximale, was du kriegen kannst, also, netto bleiben, das ist jetzt nicht so doll, was, du siehst nix, was, ach so, okay, keck, wait, jetzt seht ihr was, ne, also, das ist jetzt nicht so geil, vor allem, vor allem für München, also, das sehe ich mich nicht, ehrlich gesagt, auch so nicht, weil ich nix Neues,
nix Neues suche, aber da würde ich mich, da würde ich mich wirklich gar nicht sehen, ja, davon kannst du in München, ja, wahrscheinlich dir eine Wohnung gerade zu bezahlen, ja, also, das, das sehe ich jetzt nicht, dass das irgendjemand macht für die Kohle, zumal du, zumal du nicht vergessen darfst, also, ich finde, ganz ehrlich, so wie sich das hier liest, was du hier machst, dass du teilweise, dass du quasi alleine verantwortlich bist,
ja, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist,
Ist ja wie ein Frankfurter Flughafen.
Der ist ja auch nicht wirklich in Frankfurt.
Taktischer Hofskorb.
Aber selbst dann,
selbst wenn du weniger,
selbst wenn du weniger bezahlst für die Wohnung
als in München, ist es trotzdem
nicht viel.
Und gerade für die Verantwortung
und dass du das allein, ne, würde ich,
also das klingt echt,
nicht nach Scam, weil die meinen es ernst,
das klingt aber nach keiner
Stelle, die man sich,
die man gerne machen möchte.
Okay, wen haben wir denn als nächstes?
Jan Stonks.
Exzellent.
Geht's richtig rauf hier,
danke für den Sub.
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
MWD, mal wieder.
Aber
es gibt ja kaum jemand,
den ich bisher,
der ernsthaft einen Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration sucht.
Die suchen ja anscheinend kein
Auszubildendenstelle,
sondern wirklich
ein fachinformatikersystem.
Das finde ich interessant,
das siehst du so gut wie gar nicht mehr
nach der Ausbildung auftauchen,
diesen Begriff.
Gucken wir uns Stellen in ganz Deutschland,
ja, ich würde mir auch eine Schweizer Stelle angucken.
Also ich bin im Oktober mit meinem Master fertig,
habe meinen Bachelor Software-Dual
bei der Firma gemacht.
Während dem Master arbeite ich jedenfalls die ganze Zeit dort,
arbeite dazu 100% remote,
auch offiziell arbeite ich in Frankfurt als Entwickler.
Welches Jahresgehalt findest du an dem Master angemessen?
Keine Ahnung, aber ich sage das, was ich da immer als
Antwort darauf sage.
Nämlich,
ich habe mein damaliges Einstiegsgehalt
mal hochgerechnet
auf jetzt
und da ist das Einstieg, das wäre jetzt,
also ich habe damals 33.500 bekommen
und das wären jetzt knapp 46k.
Natürlich kannst du da vielleicht,
weil du studiert hast,
noch ein bisschen was draufhauen,
weiß nicht,
kenne ich mich zu wenig mit aus,
wie das jetzt da genau gehandhabt wird,
aber darunter würde ich es dann nicht machen.
Schau mal, gar nicht in Frankfurt.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Wir suchen echt ein Fach Informatiker System Integration.
Die RBS Netcom vom Standort Dachau aus als IT-Systemhaus
für Handwerk, Handel und Gewerbe in der Region etabliert.
Wir sind ein Team aus 15 IT-Experten.
Das ist ein kleiner Laden, oder?
Tendenz steigend.
Hochmotiviert.
Technologisch wie menschlich inspiriert.
Alter, ist ja gut.
Übertreib halt.
Hochmotiviert.
Technologisch wie menschlich inspiriert.
Begeisterungsfähig und echter Teamplayer.
Das ist nicht tactical genug, finde ich auch.
Da müssen wir die taktische Polizeihubschrauber-Staffel
mal vorbeischicken.
So.
Wir sind Berater, Betreuer,
echte Kümmerer.
Wir erkennen Zusammenhänge.
Übrigens, das hier muss nicht schlecht sein.
So ein kleiner Laden kann auch echt gut sein.
Wir sind Berater, Betreuer, echte Kümmerer.
Wir erkennen Zusammenhänge, identifizieren Risiken
und sind da, wenn es Probleme gibt.
Wir sorgen dafür, dass unsere Kunden in puncto IT
nie ein blaues Wunder erleben.
Zur Verstärkung des Teams suchen sie jetzt einen Admin.
Moment.
Sie suchen einen Admin, Fachinformatiker, IT-Support-Mitarbeiter.
Also bis hierhin könnte ich mich damit ja noch halbwegs identifizieren.
Aber der zweite Part klingt nach was,
was ich im Leben nicht freiwillig machen würde.
Support ist echt so der...
Und wenn ich das jetzt sage, meine ich nicht die Leute,
die im Support arbeiten, sondern die Arbeit an sich.
Support ist echt der komplette Bodensatz, Alter.
Okay, du möchtest nah am Kunden arbeiten, gleichzeitig...
Nee, möchte ich gar nicht.
Möchte ich gar nicht.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der nah am Kunden arbeiten möchte?
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Uwe schreibt, habe letztens eine Entwicklerstelle gesehen.
Am Ende stand bei einem...
Am Ende stand, bei einem persönlichen Gespräch
können wir am besten rüberbringen,
warum du dich für uns entscheiden solltest.
Drei Zeilen weiter drüber stand,
schick uns eine E-Mail mit folgenden Angaben,
mit dem Punkt, warum du bei uns arbeiten willst.
Entscheidet euch doch mal.
Aus denen ihrer Sicht ist das gar kein Widerspruch.
Die meinen damit wahrscheinlich,
du sollst erst mal schreiben, warum du der richtige Bewerber bist.
Und wenn sie dich dann rausgepickt haben,
dass du gut passen könntest,
dann müssen sie dich davon überzeugen,
dass sie eigentlich viel besser sind, als du vielleicht denkst.
Aus denen ihrer Sicht macht das durchaus Sinn,
ist natürlich total bescheuert geschrieben.
Willst du unsere Echse ausführen?
Netcom RBS.
Aufgaben.
Administration und Support von Clients und Servern.
Also, ich warte jetzt noch drauf,
dass da jetzt Windows Server kommt
oder Active Directory oder sowas.
Planung, Analyse, Netzwerkinfrastruktur.
Designopt...
Designoptimierung.
Aufbau und... Achso.
Okay, die meinen damit nicht wirklich Design,
irgendwas Grafisches,
sondern Architektur meinen die eher sowas.
Aufbau und Betreuung von IT-Systemen.
Management von Netzwerken und Serversystemen.
Support und Betreuung unserer...
Okay.
Da machst du wirklich alles.
Das lass ich denen aber durchgehen,
dass man hier alles macht, weil...
Das ist eine Firma mit 15 Mann.
Da macht wahrscheinlich jeder zum Teil alles.
Aber hat bestimmt auch Schwerpunkte.
Das lass ich denen aber durchgehen an der Stelle.
Bei größeren Läden mach ich mich ja da immer drüber lustig.
Okay, Qualifikationen.
Physieausbildung.
Gute Kenntnisse von Microsoft, Windows...
Nein, Gott!
Nein, Gott, bitte nein!
Praxiserfahrung im Bereich Virtualisierung, Netzwerk und Cloud.
Auffassungsgabe, kreative Problemlösung.
Ja, das meinen die so, wenn das da steht.
Seriously, in so kleinen Läden...
...da bleibt aber oftmals nichts anderes.
Da bleibt aber oftmals nichts anderes übrig.
Also...
Ich glaube, da wird noch mehr gebastelt,
als in der IT ohnehin schon.
Und das muss nichts Schlechtes sein.
Gewohnheit, Eigenverantwortung...
Umfangreise, flache Regie, Festanstellung in Vollzeit.
Flexible Arbeit...
Wie sieht's mit Homeoffice aus?
Wahrscheinlich bei 15 Mann nicht.
Vermögenswirksam, Betriebs- und Firmen...
Oh ja, nice!
Krassester Vorteil ever!
Krassester Vorteil ever für mich, ja.
Tom, ich auch.
Ich auch.
Ich hab meine Ausbildung bei einem Internetprovider gemacht.
Bei einem kleinen.
Nicht bei der Telekom oder so.
Weil immer irgendwelche Leute schreiben, ich hätte angeblich bei der Telekom meine Ausbildung
gemacht.
Hab ich nicht.
Ähm, da war das auch so.
Da wurde auch enorm viel gebastelt und da hat man schon einiges gelernt.
Ich sag ehrlich, mich persönlich spricht das überhaupt nicht an.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil ich echt keine gute Erfahrung habe.
Echt keine gute Erfahrung mit so kleinen Läden gemacht habe.
Ich mein, mein Ausbildungsbetrieb war nicht ganz so klein.
Die waren ein Ticken größer.
Die hatten so 200 Leute.
Und 50 davon waren Azubis, kein Witz.
Aber...
Das heißt nicht, dass die schlecht sein müssen.
Ich glaub, wenn man sowas mag, sowas Kleines, dann kann das durchaus gut sein.
Mich persönlich spricht's halt überhaupt nicht an.
Zumal es Windows ist.
Die würden mich auch nicht wollen.
Ich habe das nirgendwo erwähnt, welcher Provider.
Oder vielleicht mal aus Versehen.
Aber wenn ich es im Stream erwähnt habe,
dann kann ich es jetzt ja auch verraten.
Oder war das so ein Chebait
in der Richtung gerade?
Wie groß sollte die IT dann für mich sein?
Da kann ich keine speziellen Zahlen...
Das Ding ist halt,
wenn es so klein ist,
dass jeder alles macht,
inklusive Endkundensupport,
da bin ich raus. Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Max, du kannst dich eigentlich mal
als Gag...
Wisst ihr,
das könnte ich machen.
Das wäre sogar witzig.
Es ist ja nicht verboten, sich mit Fake-Daten zu bewerben, oder?
Machen wir ein schönes
AI-generiertes Peter-Agilet-Bild.
Das Einzige, was ich bräuchte, ist,
ich bräuchte eine Adresse
als Absender.
Und ich will da nicht
meine persönliche Adresse angeben.
Das heißt, ich bräuchte
ein Peter-Agilet-Anschrift.
So, was haben wir noch
so hier zu bieten?
Oh, what? Chat?
Warum sagt mir keiner Bescheid?
Was ist hier los?
Das würde ich sagen.
Alter, ich habe noch...
Ich habe noch zwei Sachen offen.
Die gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Ich lasse es hier auf.
Ich muss jetzt...
Schau mal, Verfassungsstelle.
Verfassungsschutz Bayern.
Oh, die sind ja...
Also, die Stelle sieht ja schon sowas von bayerisch aus.
Nee, das machen wir nicht heute fertig.
Es ist 22.10 Uhr.
Ihr wisst, 22 Uhr ist Bett-Getime.
Egal, ob ich Urlaub habe oder nicht.
22 Uhr.
Ich gehe eh spätestens 23 Uhr so richtig pennen.
Ich bin jemand,
der geht lieber früher schlafen und stehe früh auf.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich der Einzige,
der im Urlaub auch freiwillig
um 7 Uhr aufsteht.
Oder teilweise, wenn irgendwas ist,
sogar noch früher, aber 7 Uhr ist meistens...
Oder sogar sonntags um 7 Uhr aufsteht.
Das macht wahrscheinlich auch kaum einer.
Dafür gehe ich halt
22, 23 Uhr ins Bett.
Chat gehen.
Besser ist das, was für dich gut funktioniert.
Da gibt es kein besser und schlecht.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie was Unzusammenhängenderes gehört
bei dem Thema.
Ja, und dann schläfst du auch sofort
und dann guckst du noch Videos.
Ja und nein.
Also, ich gucke noch Videos,
aber ich penne da meistens relativ schnell bei ein.
Ich mache das so.
Also, mein Trick ist,
du guckst TikTok.
Nee, mache ich nicht.
Also, nicht abends im Bett.
Ich mache das so.
Immer, wenn ich aufs Klo muss,
ich habe ein Tablet auf dem Klo liegen.
Da gucke ich auf YouTube rum.
Und ich habe eine Playlist,
wo ich mir die Sachen speichere,
die ich mir dann abends angucken will.
Aber ich nehme da immer nur entspanntes Zeug, ja.
Also, Leute, von denen ich weiß, dass die da rumschreien
oder so, kommen da erst gar nicht rein.
Die mache ich dann abends, wenn ich mich ins Bett lege,
mache ich die auf dem Handy an.
Und dann kriege ich dann meistens gar nicht mehr alles mit.
Bis liebge...
Höre ich mir tatsächlich gerne an.
Ich finde das beruhigend.
Du wirst lachen.
Ich gucke mir tatsächlich solche Videos gerne an, ja.
Ja.
Ja, klar.
Am besten, wenn er erzählt,
dass er im Whirlpool wieder 15 Weiber geknallt hat.
Wobei, weiß ich nicht,
ob der überhaupt noch diese Art von Videos macht.
Ja, das 25 Zentimeter deutscher Stahl.
Oder wie ist das?
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Das ist nicht entspannt genug.
Ich gucke mir meistens...
So was gucke ich mir gerne an.
Über irgendwelche...
Mathematischen Sachen.
Ich gucke mir auch gerne was aus...
So Richtung Physik...
Universum und...
Solche Sachen an.
Das ist...
Ist immer sehr entspannend.
Da kann ich gut bei pennen.
Oh ne, das hat mir schon gereicht, was ich da gesehen habe vorhin auf den ersten Blick.
Koboldkonferenz.
Ja, da kann man sicherlich einschlafen.
Also ein Channel, den ich gerne gucke, ist irgendeiner, der heißt Isaac.
Irgendwas, glaube ich.
Isaac.
Der macht auch immer so irgendwelche...
Wenn man jetzt mit dem Raumschiff losfliegt bis Alpha Centauri, dann dauert das so und so lang und bla bla bla.
ASMR-Installing-Gento-Linux.
Es gibt allen Ernstes ein ASMR-Installing-Gento-Linux?
Der Wolfgang!
Ey, von dem haben wir schon ein paar Sachen geguckt.
Alter, das hat aber 181.000...
131.000...
Laufrufe, nice.
Nice.
Das ist immer...
Jetzt weiß ich, was YouTube Leute sehen wollen.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die YouTube Leute sehen wollen.
ASMR-Gento installieren.
Und mich durch den Schnee stelzen sehen.
Ja.
Das sind anscheinend die zwei Sachen, die YouTube richtig gut gehen.
So, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Wir hören uns morgen.
Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
See you.